nous entrons à l'époque des changements
mondiaux pour former un nouveau modèle
du développement du secteur qu'est ce
qui va devenir un élément moteur du
développement de notre secteur quelle
serait l'évolution des prix de
ressources lorsque la consommation la
demande de change tout le temps et
lorsqu'il y a une pression des
technologies et nous ouvrons de
nouvelles directions de livraison vers
l'est
nous produisons des produits polymères
avec une grande valeur ajoutée
grâce à l'exploration des territoires du
nord et des développements des projets
extra polaire nous utilisons des
systèmes intelligents ce qui nous permet
de reconstituer les bases de ressources
et de construire de nouveaux couloirs à
logistique à réalisant des projets
prioritaires qui dans les venir peuvent
être utilisés pour le transport de
différents types de carburant
l'énergie pure et sécuriser le
développement des technologies
alternatives
nous pousse à développer de nouveaux
modèles de développement du secteur
énergétique et des industriels cela crée
des défis et en même temps ça nous ouvre
nous offre de nouvelles opportunités qui
nous permettront de
d'assurer le développement de ce secteur
grâce aux potentialités qui sont placés
dans ce domaine
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs
président de la fédération de russie
vladimir vladimirovitch poutine
et
havelis gamble qui va modérer cette
séance plénière
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur le président votre
excellences mesdames et messieurs je
vous souhaite la bienvenue à cette
semaine russe de l'énergie qui est déjà
mahdi sion de ce forum je m'appelle adli
gamble je suis envoyé de cnbc et je
travaille normalement depuis abu dhabi
je voudrais présenter mes participant à
notre discussion
c'est patrick menais
président directeur général du groupe
total énergie nous avons aussi monsieur
bernard l'uni pdg de bp daren good pdg
d'exxon mobil et au lac à les news ce
directeur général de daimler ag et le
président de mercedes benz merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui nous sommes
confrontés à un avenir qui est
imprévisible et le réchauffement global
conformément à l'onu ce n'est pas
seulement un signal tu es triste pour
l'ensemble de la l'humanité mais c'est
aussi un très mauvais signal pour notre
planète et tout cela se produit sur fond
d'une crise énergétique et mondiale
lorsque des chaînes de livraison ont été
rompues dans le monde ce qui a constitué
les menaces dans le monde entier comme
le par exemple le retour des talibans en
afghanistan nous voyons également des
tensions en mer de chine ne sont
confrontés à des perspectives d
d'inflation de stagflation
et comme l'a dit une des personnes qui
est présente ici les banques centrales
impriment de l'argent comme des
confettis donc nous devons discuter
beaucoup de choses et donc la question
principale que vous aurez posé comment
nous allons pouvoir répondre à des
besoins de la population du monde qui
augmente parce que bientôt savoir
atteindre le seuil de 12 milliards de km
une millions et donc comment nous
pouvons éviter la destruction de la
planète et là je donne la parole aux
messieurs le président de la fédération
de russie monsieur poutine
chers amis mesdames et messieurs
je salue tous les participants et tous
les invités de cette semaine russe de
l'énergie moscou accueille de nouveau
les dirigeants des grandes sociétés du
secteur
des experts réputés et des spécialistes
de rénommée pour discuter ensemble
l'état actuel et les perspectives de
développement de l'énergie globale et
c'est tendance bien sûr évidemment pour
proposer des mécanismes d'une
stabilisation durable du marché
énergétique ce qui est très important
surtout dans cette situation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et qui a été
évoqué par notre de modératrice tout
tout tout à l'heure le secteur
énergétique a ressenti pleinement la
crise suscitée par la pandémie du carnet
virus lorsque à cause des restrictions à
cause du ralentissement des activités
dans le monde d'affaires la suspension
des productions et des transports dans
le monde entier la demande des
ressources énergétiques a baissé de
façon drastique et ceux qui sont
présents dans ces salles le savent très
bien par leur expérience pratique et
parce que cela a touché vos entreprises
pour l'année dernière la consommation
globale de l'énergie primaire a diminué
de 4,7 pour cent ce qui est devenu le
choc le plus important pour le secteur
au cours de 70 dernières années
la baisse de la demande a provoqué le
changement des prix ainsi par rapport à
2018 le coût du gaz naturel en europe
l'année dernière a diminué de deux fois
et demi
en 2020 son coût était de 113 dollars
pour mille mètres cubes en 2010 959 $ et
en 2010 8 282 $
le secteur pétrolier a connu une
situation tout à fait unique
parce que personne de nous et personne d
vous
ne pouvait y croire il ne pouvait pas
imaginer lorsque un automne dernier au
plus tôt à l'automne de l'année dernière
le coût du pétrole a basculé vers des
valeurs négatives
donc il fallait il fallait payer pour
qu'on vous achète du pétrole
le rôle clé dans la stabilisation du
marché pétrolier a été jouée par les
accords dans le cadre de paix peu plus
les membres de l'apec et les états qui
ne font partie de cette organisation ont
su mettre au point une coopération
efficace et d'assurer dans les
conditions de la pandémie la stabilité
de ce secteur est de créer les
conditions pour les investissements
parce que si les investissements
s'arrête pour de nouveaux gisements pour
la production du pétrole le marché
serait confondre et un déficit critique
d'un les temps les plus proches mais il
faut dire aussi recueilli il ya
certaines choses que nous et nous
observons aussi aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
la relance de l'économie mondiale et de
la demande du pétrole
contribue à la stabilisation du marché
et des prix
ce qui permet d'augmenter la production
du pétrole de façon
opérationnelle et de façon rapide la
russie est un membre responsable de
l'apec plus et nous pensons que les
accords qui ont été conclus vont être en
vigueur jusqu'à la fin de l'année
prochaine
en même temps il y a des chances toutes
les chances que la coopération se
développe au sein de cette organisation
et peut s'étendre à de nouvelles et
direction y compris la mise au point de
nouvelles technologies
l'échangé des meilleures pratiques et
les pratiques de mesures de réduction de
la trace carbone à la différence du
pétrole la situation dans le marché
gazier sur tout le marché européen ne
semble pas être équilibré et prévisible
est la principale raison c'est que tout
sur ce marché ne dépend pas des
producteurs très souvent les
consommateurs du gaz joue un rôle qui
n'est pas moindre et même parfois plus
important et je veux maintenant vous
dire quelques certaines choses qui
pour vous les professionnels peuvent
sembler évidente peuvent sembler des
lieux communs mais ces derniers temps
des responsables différents pays
préfèrent oublier ces choses là où ne
pas en parler les terres
ainsi donc les
slogans politiques et creux se met à la
place d'une analyse de la situation de
quoi il s'agit au cours des dix
dernières années la part des énergies
renouvelables dans le mix européen a
augmenté de façon très importante et
rapide
on dirait que c'est bien parce que
maintenant ces
énergies joue un rôle très important
et donc dieu merci et pourtant la
particularité essentielle de ce secteur
c'est que la production de l'énergie
électrique ne savait pas de façon
permanente
donc pour cela il faut avoir des grandes
capacités de réserve et s'il ya une
chute importante
dans la production de l'énergie
électrique par exemple à cause des
conditions météorologiques alors ces
réserves peuvent s'avérer ne pas
suffisante
c'est ce qui s'est produit cette année
lorsque à cause de la diminution de la
production de l'électricité par des
éoliennes le marché européen a connu un
déficit de l'énergie électrique ces prix
ont flambé ce qui a provoqué
la hausse des prix du gaz et sur le
marché spot
il faut savoir qu'il ya une chose qui
est très importante à la consommation du
gaz dépend beaucoup de la saison en été
ces stocks sont traditionnellement
reconstituer avant la période d'hiver et
pourtant cette année même après les
verts qui étaient froids en europe de
nombreux pays ne l'ont pas fait ils ont
placé leurs espoirs dans les livraisons
spots dans cette main invisible du
marché
ainsi dans les conditions de cette
demande de fébriles cela a accéléré
encore plus la hausse des primes je
voudrais répéter à quoi une fois que
l'augmentation du coût du gaz en europe
est défini une conséquence du difficile
de l'énergie électrique ce n'est pas le
vice versa et donc il faut pas
acheter sa mauvaise conscience sur les
autres comme le font certains de nos
partenaires parfois on les écoute
on
s'étonne tout simplement
comme si nos partenaires ne voyait pas
des choses réelles des chiffres
au cours de cette dernière décennie
petit à petit les défauts systémiques se
multiplient dans le secteur énergétique
européen qui ont conduit justement à
cette crise du marché très importante je
voudrais vous rappeler que tant que la
production électrique
très dominés dans les centrales
nucléaires et à gaz et il n'y avait pas
de ceux crise là parce que tout
simplement il n'y a pas de raison pour
que ces crises surviennent je voudrais
ajouter que en russie ce type de
problème
est impossible d'imaginer
parce que notre approche durable au
développement du secteur énergétique
permet d'assurer des prix de l'énergie
électrique et pour la population et des
entreprises au niveau le plus bas en
europe par exemple le coût moyen de
l'énergie électrique en russie est de 20
euros pour mégawatt/heure alors qu'en
lituanie 7 256 euros en allemagne de
france 300 euros au royaume-uni 320
euros
la hausse de coûts est limité et très
bien régulé dans notre pays à la
différence des pays européens ou à cause
de l'augmentation de
darif de l'énergie électrique le coût
des services communaux ces derniers
temps montrent pratiquement tous les
mois
j'ai des données mais je ne veux pas
vous fatiguer avec ces chiffres-là
revenant la situation sur le marché
gazier je voudrais dire encore que des
mots on entend dire souvent que les
coûts élevés font le jeu des producteurs
leur permettant d'avoir des profits
énormes sans fournir
de des efforts visibles mais ceux qui
partagent ce point de vue ont une vision
étroite des choses il préfère ne pas
regarder de l'avant ne pas tenir compte
des perspectives à long terme alors que
ses perspectives c'est évident même pour
les producteurs il y à des risques de
d'élévation des prix très important ce
qui entraîne les entreprises l'économie
et les services communaux dans une
situation de hausse radicale du coup et
donc nous oblige à réduire la
consommation de l'énergie à réduire la
production est donc finalement les prix
élevés peut tourner en des conséquences
négatives pour tout le monde y compris
pour les producteurs y compris pour nos
producteurs et je pense que nos
producteurs y compris ceux qui sont
présents dans ces salles le comprennent
très très bien pour tout marché ce qui
est important c'est la stabilité et la
prévisibilité la russie remplit
pleinement ses obligations ses
engagements contractuels devant l'europe
et assure des livraisons continuent de
gaz
il y a tout les prémices pour que à la
fin de cette année nous allons donc
passer à des livraisons records du gaz
vers le marché mondial qui plus est nous
allons toujours à la rencontre de nos
partenaires et nous sommes toujours
prêts à discuter des contributions
supplémentaires nous travaillons de
façon conséquente
pour renforcer la sécurité énergétique
du continent du continent nous réalisons
avec nos partenaires européens des
infrastructures très importants tels que
turquie streamé balkans stream et nord
stream 2
dont la mission est d'assurer la
stabilité et la prévisibilité des
livraisons de gaz dans des volumes qui
sont nécessaires pour les pays de
l'europe je voudrais ajouter que la
réalisation de ces projets conduit à une
diminution de plusieurs fois des
émissions des gaz à effet de serre
pour préciser je peux vous dire que la
trace carbone des livraisons du gaz
naturel russe à travers le nord stream
qui est marche déjà et trois fois moins
importante que pour les livraisons du
gaz naturel liquéfié des américains il
faut maintenant essayer de trouver des
mécanismes globaux de
pour assurer l'équilibré des
du marché énergétique il faut voir des
mécanismes qu'il serait libre des
préjugés politiques et des stéréotypes
imposé il s'agit des questions très
importantes dont dépend directement le
fonctionnement des entreprises et le
bien-être des ménages et des millions de
personnes en russie
comme dans les pays partenaires y
compris les pays européens je suis
persuadé que dans le cadre du cycle de
dialogue nous pouvons trouver des
solutions qui tiendrait compte des
tendances du marché d intérêt de tous
les partis
chaque collègue l'un des principaux
facteurs qui définit ce développement du
secteur énergétique mondial à long terme
c'est bien sûr le changement climatique
la russie est pleinement consciente de
la gravité des défis dans ce domaine
nous ressentons nous comprenons toutes
les menaces tous les risques pour
l'humanité et pour la planète entière
mais aussi pour notre pays dans notre
pays la température annuelle moyenne
augmente deux fois et demie plus
rapidement que la moyenne globale depuis
dix ans elle a augmenté de presque un
demi degré dans les régions arctiques
cette rapidité de réchauffement est
encore plus importante la russie
soutenait
internationale pour la préservation du
climat elle remplit ses engagements et
donc l'horizon de quelques décennies
nous envisageons d'assurer un volume
accumulé des émissions nettes des gaz à
effet de serre à un niveau inférieur au
niveau européen je reconnais que ce ne
sont pas des paroles vides c'est une
instruction d'agir nous sommes en train
de mettre à l'heure des projets qui
doivent déjà des résultats qui donneront
des résultats sur plusieurs années les
entreprises russes du secteur pétrolier
gazier
réduisent brûlage
de 15 ans saucier et je viens de le dire
une réunion nous avons des résultats
souvent meilleure que dans le monde nous
lançons des projets pour la captation de
co2 nous appliquons des normes plus
strictes technologique nous
réalisons un grand travail pour
moderniser l'énergie électrique le
secteur énergétique et le secteur
communal nous allons continuer de
soutenir ces initiatives le potentiel
russe ou augmenter l'efficacité
énergétique est un énorme évalue à un
tiers de la consommation actuelle et je
charge le gouvernement d' actualiser le
programme national
économies d'énergie et augmentation de
l'efficacité énergétique nous avons
parlé récemment réunion de cela nous
allons prolonger ce programme à 2035 un
consolidant notre travail dans tous les
secteurs qui s'ajuste l'industrie les
transports
l'agriculture des services communaux
pour
arriver à des objectifs ambitieux pour
réduire l'intensité énergétique
la russie
essayé d'arriver à la neutralité carbone
de son économie notre repère c'est de le
réaliser au plus tard en 2060 je vais
répéter la préservation du climat c'est
l'objectif commun de toute l'humanité il
y aura un travail énorme compliqué
intense avec la participation de
nombreux experts dirigeants des
entreprises associations autorités
publiques
jantes à climatique
ne doit pas devenir un instrument pour
faire avancer des intérêts économiques
et politiques de certains pays nous
devons créer
les règles uniques équitable pour tous
de réglementation thématiques qui seront
en vigueur au niveau global basé sur le
vrai souci de l'état du climat sur la
compréhension du rôle de l'apport de
chaque pays
basé sur des modèles mutuellement
reconnu de mesures de suivi de
l'absorption de l'émission des gaz à
effet de serre il faut suivre les
principes de neutralité technologique
c'est à dire calculés la trace carbone
des différents types de génération il ya
très peu de gens qui savent que présente
la trace carbone de l'énergie atomique
est inférieure à l'énergie solaire nous
avons des experts dans cette salle et
certains peut-être l'entente pour la
première fois la russie possède une
expérience pratique énorme de
l'exploitation
de développement d'exploitation
d'ethnologie atomique notamment un
réacteur à neutrons rapides qui au terme
permettront d'arriver aussi que le
combustible fermé l'utilisation de
petits réacteurs atomiques d'ailleurs
une centrale flottante
atomique de faible capacité
est déjà opérationnel dans le nord-est
du pays du code k
en s'appuyant sur les réalisations dans
ce domaine nous continuerons les
exportations des technologies tomic ce
sera notre rapport à la décarbonisation
du secteur énergétique mondiale bien sûr
le rôle clé dans le sociaux de ce
problème doit être réparé des projets
climatiques notamment des projets qui
utilise le potentiel des écosystèmes
naturels la la rue cibles proposées
offrir des opportunités uniques
l'efficacité de ce projet dans notre
pays est bien supérieur que celle des
investissements dans les projets de
européen de jim renouvelables
si pour créer des conditions de travail
plus confortable dans la commune de
faire il faut créer des conditions pour
attirer des investissements dans les
projets qui donnent le meilleur effet
bien sûr il n'ya pas de place dans ce
domaine pour des sanctions pour
différentes restrictions autre chose la
discussion actuelle nous montre que la
préservation du climat ce d'un problème
qui doit être résolu en coordination
étroite avec les plans de développement
de l'économie surtout du secteur
énergétique d'après les experts elle
raison de vingt cinq ans la part des
hydrocarbures dans le mix énergétique
mondial peut se réduire à 7 81 85 %
actuels à 60 65 % le rôle du pétrole du
charbon va se réduire va être réduit des
personnes présentes dans cette salle nos
collègues russes sont pleinement
conscients de cela et partent de ce
principe le rôle du gaz naturel
comme un carburant de transition europe
augmenté il s'agit notamment d'augmenter
la production de gnl à l'horizon 2035
nous espérons faire passer la production
de gnl en russie à 140 millions de
tonnes par an et de consolider notre
position sur ce marché dynamique
c'est d'arriver à 20% grâce au coût de
revient va est une logistique
concurrentiel
compétitive
la route maritime du nord transporte
avant tout aujourd'hui comme marchandise
le gnl à l'horizon 2035 nous espérons
faire passer de 1 % à 7 % de notre part
dans les livraisons globales de produits
peut-être au gazole chimiques sur
à l'horizon de quelques décennies le
rôle de l'hydrogène de l'ammoniac va
augmenter dans l'énergie mondiale
se serviront de matière première de
carburant de sources d'énergie nous
avons en russie des
possibilités scientifiques de des
ressources de ressources logistiques
pour occuper une part importante sur ses
marchés à vladivostok lors du forum
économique récent j'ai déjà parlé à ce
sujet je appeler nos collègues de la
région asie pacifique de participer de
coopérer j'espère que nos collègues de
l'europe des états unis deux autres pays
vont également répondre à cet appel
chers collègues les nathan 10 me le choc
des marchés énergétiques
régionaux nous ont montré à quel point
le fonctionnement stable viable vis du
secteur énergétique sont importants
ceci avec
l' impact minimal sur l'environnement
pour assurer la sécurité énergétique et
écologique de la planète il faut que
tous les participants tous les acteurs
du marchés agissent d'une manière
responsable
de ses actions soit orientée à long
terme ceci dans l'intérêt du
développement durable de nos pays et de
nos peuples et russie est prête à cette
coopération basée sur la créativité et
sur la confiance notamment à nous sommes
prêts au dialogue direct avec nos
partenaires en europe pour re trouver
des solutions communes pour stabiliser
le marché dont le thé contre le
changement climatique nous je suis sûr
que nous arriverons ensemble à ce
objectif je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
pour ce commentaire
nous allons donc faire
maintenant passée l'intervention du
président de la république d'angola
votre excellence monsieur le président
de la fédération de russie vladimir
poutine
mesdames et messieurs participants
feront mesdames et messieurs
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité à
participer à la semaine russe de
l'énergie qui soulève des questions
pertinentes non seulement pour le pays
hôte mais aussi pour tous les pays où le
pétrole et le gaz et la production de
cesse de ressources est la principale
source possible de l'énergie
c'est le cas de l'angola ou le pétrole
ou le gaz
constitue la principale source de revenu
national
aujourd'hui l'angola produit environ 1,3
million de barils de pétrole
et
76,4 millions de mètres cubes de gaz
naturel par jour
malgré la présence de compagnies
pétrolières internationales en angola il
ya aussi de la place pour d'autres
investisseurs
principalement dans des zones franches
et au niveau de nouveaux bassins à tour
les sédiments terre où le potentiel
d'hydrocarbures
inexploré n'a pas encore été pleinement
évalué
lingots la restructurer son secteur
pétrolier avec la création de l'agencé
nationale du pétrole du gaz et des
biocarburants qui a prise en charge
l'attribution des concessions et la
réglementation en amont en matière de
prospection nous avons également créé
l'institut de
régulation de régulation des dérivés du
pétrole qui a reçu les fonctions de
réguler
les productions alors que son un goal
est restée concentrée sur la valeur
ajoutée du secteur pétrolier c'est à
dire la prospection l'exploration
l'évolution le développement et la
production du pétrole brut et du gaz
naturel ainsi que le raffinage le
transport le stockage et la
commercialisation des produits
pétroliers
les activités de développement et de
production d'hydrocarbures sont
précieusement principalement limités au
pétrole brut néanmoins compte tenu de la
nécessité de libérer le potentiel
économique des réserves de gaz naturel
existant en angola et afin de cesser de
le brûlage des gaz un projet a été lancé
pour construire une usine de
l'équitation angola l enchère
gnl dans le cadre d'un partenariat entre
sur l'angola chevron bp eni et total
energy
afin d'exploiter efficacement les
gisements d'hydrocarbures gazeux est de
promouvoir la diversification économique
le président adopter un de créer cette
barre 18 en date du 18 mai 2018 qui
établit le régime juridique et fiscal
des activités dans le domaine de la
prospection de la recherche de
l'évaluation du
développement de l'exploration de la
production de la conversation du gaz
naturel afin de stimuler la production
des gaz ainsi que les secteurs connexes
dans ce contexte les actions sont en
cours pour établir
et créer nouveau consortium gazier pour
la production de gaz non associé qui
permettra la fourniture interrompu de
gaz à luzy angola elle gnl et par la
suite de fournir du gaz au centre de
cycle combiné qui fonctions dans la
ville de soyaux et à l'industrie des
engrais entre autres projets visant la
diversification de l'économie angolaise
le développement du secteur gazier offre
des possibilités aux entreprises russes
notamment compte tenu de leur expérience
dans ce domaine pour par exemple aider à
la création de la production d'acier la
construction des usines d'engrais la
production d'électricité et cetera
toujours pour lancer le cycle de
production du secteur pétrolier et
gazier le gouvernement a adopté une
stratégie des hydrocarbures pour la
période 2020 et 2025
visant à recueillir plus de données
géologiques et assurer
l'accès à des ressources et pétrolier
des bassins sédimentaires angolais afin
de récupérer et d'augmenter les réserves
de pétrole
afin d'augmenter le volume de la
production pétrolière en angola le
gouvernement a adopté une nouvelle
stratégie de quoi de l'essence pour les
blocs pétroliers pour la période 2010 9
2025 qui prévoit la délivrance de permis
de développement de l'exploration pour
plus de 50 bloc pour compléter et
renforcer sa stratégie le gouvernement a
également mis en place le régime
d'offres permanente de bloc notes i
visant à promouvoir et travailler en
permanence en matière de vente de blocs
sur l'essence pour le développement des
quais l'aider à cornes
deux concessions n'ont pas encore été
émis ainsi que sur les hommes libres de
blocs de concession et sur les
concessions détenues par le service
national pour la distribution des
concessions ce qui ouvre aussi des
opportunités pour les entreprises russes
afin d'assurer l'autosuffisance du pays
en produits raffinés le gouvernement
encourage les projets de construction de
trois raffineries
dans les villes de cabinda de soyaux et
de lobito avec la construction de ces
raffineries l'angola aura une capacité
de traitement d'environ
420 5000 barils de pétrole brut par jour
il existe des opportunités pour les
entreprises refusent d'investir dans la
construction de la raffinée de lobby
tout le bit au actuellement on appel
d'offres international pour un
partenariat pas de ses fils est en cours
est encore en cours et parce que cet
appel d'offres soit clôturée en octobre
de cette année
l'industrie pétrolière d'une source
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
contribuant ainsi au réchauffement
climatique et donc dans ce contexte le
gouvernement angolais appelle tous les
opérateurs
impliqués dans l'exploitation est
l'expression du pétrole du gaz à prendre
des mesures afin d'atténuer et de
compenser
les effets nocifs
tels que la gestion de l'énergie le
boisement la rue bois et le reboisement
et c'est un autre compte tenu de la
progression rapide du changement
climatique et des préoccupations
environnementales croissantes
la transition énergétique vers une
économie à faible émission de carbone
est aujourd'hui l'un des principaux
thèmes politiques de divers pays ainsi
l'angola à l'instar d'autres pays doit
développer une stratégie nationale dans
le but de produire durablement ses
ressources énergétiques fossiles afin de
s'orienter vers un changement progressif
de la matrice énergétique nationale à
moyen et long terme en créant des
opportunités pour le développement de
nouvelles énergies renouvelables telles
que l'énergie du soleil du vent de la
biomasse et autres à cette fin la
société sont un goal ep un partenariat
avec les compagnies pétrolières eni et
total energy développe deux projets de
centrales photovoltaïques et dans les
provinces de namibe et du est là
en explorant également des projets de
production de biocarburants et
d'hydrogène
en conclusion je voudrais souligner une
importance de contribution de la
fédération de russie à la formation des
cadres techniques angolais dans le
secteur pétrolier seul domaine dans
lequel la poursuite de la coopération
revêt une importance sans précédent pour
le développement social et économique de
notre pays
une fois de plus j'exprime ma gratitude
pour l'invitation à participer à ce
forum et je déclare que l'angola a un
très grand intérêt à renforcer sa
coopération avec la fédération de russie
dans ce domaine et dans d'autres
domaines et notre désir aussi que notre
pays est ouvert à toutes les entreprises
qui voudraient participer à leur
investissement la diversification et au
développement de l'économie angolaise
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le président
vous avez parlez dans votre intervention
de la crise gazière je pense que nous
pouvons poursuivre rebondir sur ce sujet
vous avez également dit que il ne faut
pas remettre ça en laisse pression sur
les autres vous avez parlé des slogans
politiques et pendant la dérive mais on
a beaucoup parlé de ce qui se passe je
voudrais poser une question directe
est-ce que la russie utilise l'énergie
comme une arme
la russie n'utilise aucune arme si vous
y avez prêté attention et ainsi booster
l'économie rousse que nous utilisons
ces armes dans quel conflit nous
participons donc quand l économie c'est
tout simplement exclus même dans les
périodes les plus difficiles de la
guerre froide la russie a
toujours respecté ses engagements
contractuels et livrer du gaz à l'europe
il faut dire que à cette époque-là
vos compatriotes les américains ont
lutté contre ce projet les tubes contre
les gaz mais la direction de l'allemagne
fédérale à de l'époque a insisté pour
que ce projet soit réalisé qui est
encore un marché qui participent de
façon très activement à l' équilibre du
mix énergétique en europe c'est ce qui
constitue justement une sorte de
bavardages politiquement motivée qui n'a
pas de fondement
je parle donc de ces accusations
selon lesquelles nous utiliserons nous
utiliserions l'énergie en tant qu'arme
regardez un peu ce qui se passe aussi
l'europe produit quelques 50 milliards
de kilomètres de mètres cubes de
gaz par an et cette production va
baisser dans plusieurs pays en allemagne
au royaume uni et ses seuls gasprom
produit plus de
500 milliards de mètres cubes de gaz par
an et cette production va augmenter
parce que les
réserves du gaz pauvre con son au niveau
de 35 mille milliards de mètres cubes on
peut dire que les réserves de la russie
sont au niveau planétaire et sont
illimitées et nous augmentons les
livraisons du gaz en europe même quand
nous connaissons des conditions
difficiles nous mêmes
je pense que le gazprom a augmenté ses
livraisons de 10% à peu près vers
l'europe et dans son ensemble à
l'augmentation de la livraison du gaz en
europe est de 15% à peu près en y
ajoutant le gaz naturel liquifié parce
que cela
les livraisons de gaz
liquéfié
ont augmenté de quelques 14 ou 15
passant je ne me souviens d'aucun cas
dans lequel nos sociétés ont refusé de
répondre à des besoins supplémentaires
de nos partenaires même pendant les
périodes d hiver froide si on nous
demandait d'augmenter les livraisons en
plus des nos engagements contractuels
nous l'avons toujours fait et nous
continuons de le faire
donc nous justement nous livre nous
livrons ce que est demandée par nos
partenaires je voudrais également
attirer votre attention sur un autre
élément parce que par exemple les
livraisons du gaz liquéfié
américains sont partis en quittant
l'europe vers l'asie lorsque les prix
ont été
favorables pour cette diversion et donc
les
les volumes pour l'europe qui est de
14 milliards de mètres cubes de gaz
sur ses livraisons totales la moitié à
peu près n'est pas livrée par les
opérateurs américains donc
si la question se pose ainsi donc qui
utilisent ces instruments énergétique
dans leur propre intérêt nous
autres personnes nous augmentons nos
livraisons alors que les partenaires des
autres pays y compris les américains
diminue les livraisons ce sont des
choses tout à fait ouverte les données
ouvertes il suffit de
regardez sur internet tout est là bas et
alors vous dites
vous parler de ces accusations de la
russie
à matière d'utilisation de l'énergie en
tant qu'arme c'est
ce sont des bavardages politiquement
motivée qui n'a aucun fondement
voilà c'est ce que je voulais dire
aujourd'hui
consommation européenne de gaz soixante
pour cent des prix augmente énormément
comment est ce que vous pouvez faire
croire lorsque vous êtes un partenaire
fiable
dans le domaine gazier puisque vous ne
fournissez pas autant d'énergie via les
gazoducs
vous savez j'ai devant moi une personne
très sympathique mais j'ai l'impression
que je ne m'entends pas
je vais vous répéter
non monsieur le président je vous ai
bien entendu mais je conduis cette
question alors vous dites vous livrer le
gaz
par le gazoduc est il souvent on est
trompé ceux qui puisent la formation
dans ces sources se trompe nous
augmentons les livraisons vers l'europe
le gasprom 10% la russie entière de 15%
plus de livraison 10% via les gazoducs +
13 % de mg nous ne réduisons pas les
raisons nous augmentons bien les
livraisons d'autres fournisseurs ont
réduit les maisons de 14 milliards de
mètres cubes donc la moitié
la moitié de cette réduction appartient
aux fournisseurs américains
non nous augmentons
livraison si on nous demande augmenter
encore plus nous sommes prêts à
augmenter encore nous augmentons
alors pourtant que les partenaires nous
le demande nous ne refusons jamais
jamais nous
augmentons cette
livraison
vers la turquie
le stream que le turc stream
vers les balkans
via le sûr que je trime et
via tous les itinéraires existants et
même via le système de transport de gaz
de l'ukraine
augmentation cette année via les
gazoducs qui passe par l'ukraine en plus
de nos engagements contractuels ça de
plus de 10% mais on peut pas augmenter
on nous dise augmenter les livraisons
via l'ukraine
mais c'est pas possible depuis des
dizaines d'années les gazoducs qui passe
pas l'ukraine n'ont pas été rénovés et
puis si on augmente la pression il y
aura une explosion carrément 80 % des
équipements sont vétustes en ukraine
mais il ya des gens qui ne veulent pas
écouter qui veulent juste accusé la
russie et surtout
eux c'est qu'ils aient les partenaires
hors pair
aux ce qui les légions de mauvaise
volonté qui sont en europe ou dans
d'autres pays du monde voilà
d'accord pouvez vous nous expliquer les
marchés essaient d'arriver à une
stabilité est ce que vous voulez dire
que
vous êtes capables d'augmenter les
raisons de encore 15% parce que d'après
l'agent ce mondial
l'interaction de l'énergie
une augmentation de 15% la calmer les
marchés nous avons déjà augmenté de 15 %
sur les 9 mois de l'année en cours les
livraisons du gaz vers l'europe ont
augmenté ont bien augmenté de 15% le
problème n'est pas en russie le problème
est en europe ils n'ont pas
rempli
[Musique]
suffisamment l'or
capacité de
stockage dans les stocks souterrains
le ton était rempli de 75%
seulement réservoirs souterrains tout le
monde le comprend les livraisons des
autres régions vers l'europe ont été
réduits depuis les etats-unis notamment
nous avons augmenté les raisons les
états unis ont réduit les maisons ce qui
a provoqué une panique une partie du gaz
une partie de ressources énergétiques
sont stockés dans les réservoirs
souterrains en ukraine n'est pas de
données exactes mais il s'agit d'environ
18 milliards de mètres cubes de gaz ont
été pompés dans l'est
dans les réservoirs souterrains en
ukraine une partie très importante de
ceux
de ce volume appartient non pas aux
opérateur ukrainien mais aux opérateurs
privés et européens notamment nos
partenaires
occidentaux savent ce qui se passe dans
le secteur un physique européens
notamment en 2008 nous n'avons pas qu
obtenir le gaz qui était secret qui nous
appartenait parce que la crise avec
l'ukraine en 2008
provenait du fait que les ukrainiens ne
nous ont pas rendus notre gaz et on sait
le consommer certains politiciens peu
responsables disent il faut nationaliser
ce garde mais qui n'appartient pas aux
ukrainiens qu'est ce que nous observons
alors c'est que progressivement le gaz
est pompée en provenance de ces par ces
opérateurs privés de ces
stocks souterrains de ces réservoirs
souterrains étrangers notamment nous
sommes prêts à livrer encore plus mais
il faut des commandes nous augmentons
suivant les commandeurs aujourd'hui
c'est plus
soc 13 % nous allons encore augmenter si
nécessaire
tout ceci dans le cadre de nos
engagements contractuels nous
respectons bien nos engagements
contractuels mais sommes prêts à livrer
en dessus en plus de ses engagements
mais il faut bien la demande nous
livrons autant qu'on nous demande
nous n'avons jamais refusé une livraison
d'accord
pourriez vous nous dire
si
il n'y aurait pas de tentative
d'extorsion
via les prix il ya une pression
différente ça c'est une bonne question
c'est la deuxième question très
importante nos partenaires revient je ne
déjà dit
ceci concerne surtout la compulsion
présidente de la commission européenne
il voulait absolument créer une bourse
iob européen il
considérait que l'offre sur le marché
libre vous assurer l'équilibré du marché
énergétique nous leur avons déjà dit il
faut s'orienter à des contrats long
terme les systèmes de formation de prix
sont différents parce que dans les
contrats long terme la formation de prix
est telle qu'elle est
lié aux prix du pétrole brut sur marché
mondial plus d'autres facteurs
gazole d'autres
produits dérivés du pétrole
ce n'est pas un système secret c'est un
système qui correspond tout à fait aux
règles du marché qui est lié à des bris
de pétrole coté en bourse
mondiale
en plus
ce
prix de gaz change moins rapidement que
le prix du pétrole ce qui permet aux
opérateurs et aux consommateurs de
s'adapter de corriger si nécessaire
alors au niveau des prix spot le prix
est fort mais autrement ça dépend de la
demande mais ça dépend aussi des autres
facteurs qui sont qu'il est difficile de
pronostiquer
l'hiver était froid long dont on n'a pas
mis suffisamment de gaz dans les
réservoirs
les éoliennes sont arrêtés les prix en
asie ont augmenté et le gaz s'est dirigé
vers l'asie
pour détriment de l'europe c'est ça qui
a assuré cette flambée des prix sur le
marché européen mais gazprom ne reçoit
2000 pour
2000 dollars ni
1500 ni 1200 ce
225 nous vendons aux prix qui est lié
aux prix du pétrole qu'elle est là le
prix du pétrole maintenant c'est 81 82
n'est ce pas nous avons ici les
dirigeants des entreprises pétrolières
éléments ils savent mieux
gazprom ne
reçoit pas le prix ce prix de 2000 son
prix le prix qu'il obtient le paiement
qui l'obtient est liée au prix du m
nous avons donc construit le
stream 1 maintenant le séno stream
2 que nous avons réalisé avec
l'allemagne
l'allemagne reçoit le gaz non pas au
prix de
2000 pour 1000 mètres cubes mais au prix
de 250 300
mètres cubes
gasp homme perd même parce que si
gazprom avait vendu sur ma chaise spot
il aurait obtenu plus mais le gasprom le
fabricant le producteur est intéressé
par cette stabilité parce qu'il sait que
à long terme il va livrer à ce prix et
donc gazprom pourra établir construire
sa politique d'investissement c'est
intéressant pour le fournisseur mais
aussi pour le consommateur
dit s'il vous plaît quel est le prix
juste du gaz russe quel est le prix
juste si
le pétrole est à ce prix là vous dites
écoutez le prix juste n'est pas
réglementée par des directives se plie
et
définit d'après le marché du pétrole le
marché du pétrole a chuté la dernière il
ya deux ans et les prix du gaz ont chuté
de suite gazprom et ben a souffert
financièrement n'est ce pas
gazprom a réduit
l'extraction la production et le
bénéfice tout a été réduit ensuite les
prix du pétrole ont commencé à augmenter
et alors les bénéfices de gazprom compte
également
augmenter mais gazprom ne joue pas sur
les prix spéculatifs spot en europe et
les gens qui ne regardent les gens qui
sont ici il faut que vous que tout le
monde comprenne c'est le prix du pétrole
qui définit ce que gazprom obtient pour
le gaz
ce n'est pas les 2000 $ qui cette
flambée la bourse de londres et non
il faut que les allemands disent un
grand merci à gerard schröder
parce que maintenant l'allemagne achète
le gaz non pas à 1500 mais à 300 $ parce
que c'était un chrono long terme ceux-ci
influence les situations dans les
ménages allemands dans l'industrie
allemande en l'économie allemande
monsieur le président
il via une question très importante
vous avez dit
il ya des gens
qui accuse les autres il y a quelqu'un
qui quitte le poste maintenant c'est un
gala merkel chancelière allemande et l'a
toujours appelé à utiliser le système de
gazoducs ukrainiens pour la transiter le
gaz russe a après 2001 4 notamment
pourriez-vous le commenter effectivement
madame merkel n'accuse jeu mais la
russie là c'est un peu trop fort parce
que nous avons de très forte
contradiction avec madame merkel l'a
formulé des prétentions mais pas au
niveau de nos stream ii n'ont
effectivement elle ne critique pas nord
stream ii parce que elle et moi nous
sommes toujours partie du fait que c'est
un projet
commercial et non pas politique certains
ont dit c'est un projet qui est purement
politique que la russie va perdre mais
ce qu'est la russie veut avoir des gains
politiques c'est pour contourner
l'ukraine c'est pour contourner le
kremlin qu'on a réalisé le sur ustream
le nord stream et nord stream de ceux
qui le disent ils disent des bêtises et
je vais vous dire pourquoi
c'est parce que les gazoducs ukrainiens
ont été construits en partant du
principe
que la l'extraction et est réalisé à
ringo un groupe de jugement de rengo riz
c'est
justement ce sont aujourd'hui plus ou
moins épuisé aujourd'hui nous réalisons
l'extraction plus au nord dans péninsule
de yamal nous construisons des gazoducs
dans la russie
progressivement depuis de dizaines
d'années et 7 à partir de là que nous
avons décidé de construire leur stream
et nord stream 2 quant à la motivation
politique cet itinéraire écoutez moi
s'il vous plaît
c'est de 1000 kilomètres plus court pour
arriver à nos consommateurs principaux
en europe que l'itinéraire via l'ukraine
- 2015 et donc moins cher
le transit est plus court et c'est donc
moins cher justement pour les
consommateurs finaux parce que le prix
du transit et bien dans le pli finale du
consommateur en allemagne dans l'union
européenne
c'est à c'est plus court mais c'est
moins cher et puis c'est il s'agit des
équipements modernes
vous avez des tuyaux qui permettent une
pression plus forte c'est quoi une
station de transit de gaz c'est une
petite usine alors pour faire avancer le
gaz dans le tuyau dans le gazoduc
il faut il faut bien comprendre sur le
nord stream 1 dans scream 2 des
émissions vers l'atmosphère
sont de
5,6 fois
moins importante co2 que en cas de
transit par l'ukraine
donc lorsqu'on dit que c'est motivé
politiquement ceux qui le disent
ils ignorent les choses évidentes et
ceux qui ont des motifs politiques pour
le dire tandis que nord stream et nord
stream ii sont des projets purement
économique c'est la position de la
chancelière je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec elle
après 2020 4 êtes vous prêt à faire
transiter le gaz par l'ukraine toujours
c'est une question purement économique
le système des gazoducs ukrainiens
extrêmement vétustes
80 85 % de tuyaux vétuste pour conserver
haut et a fortiori augmentait ce transit
de gaz nous sommes en train d'augmenter
malgré divergences politiques plus 10%
cette année par l'ukraine alors en
dessus de nos contrats il faut nous dire
merci quand même au lieu de ce merci on
est en train de critiquer tout le temps
alors pour continuer le transit il faut
réparer le système ça nous concerne ça
concerne les consommateurs en europe ça
concerne les opérateurs ukrainien ça
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
il faut qu'on comprenne combien est-ce
qu'on pourra vendre ça c'est une
question très importante je les dis à
madame merkel elle pose cette question
devant nous également en répondant à
votre question je vais vous dire nous
sommes prêts à prolonger ce contrat
si les conditions économiques et
technologiques sont réunies nous sommes
prêts même à augmenter le transit mais
il faut bien comprendre il les
consommateurs vont acheter combien il y
aura certainement des questions
écologiques qui seront discutées
aujourd'hui
transit vers la l'économie bas carbone
problème de trace carbone si l'europe
abandonne les hydrocarbures et notamment
le gaz en perspective à terme alors
comment est-ce qu'on peut prendre des
engagements d'augmenter le transit par
l'ukraine si l'europe ne va pas un jour
ne va plus acheter ce gaz
dites-nous vous allez acheter combien
signe des contrats
nous allons comprendre comment nous
pourrons faire transiter par le
cinéraire nord par le turc stream
combien nous pourrons laisser augmenter
il ya l'ukraine il faut qu'on comprenne
le volume du marché
lorsque l'euro petit nous abandonnons
les et au carbure alors après 2020 4
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on va encore
pompey sentant via l'ukraine
c'est pas normal que de comptes de
réfléchir comme ça il faut tout calculer
d'abord
est ce que nous sommes prêts oui la
réponse est oui nous avons tout calculé
le vice président du gouvernement de la
fédération de russie messieurs novak a
dit la semaine dernière
que
la levée des difficultés régulatrice
rapide avant la mise en fonctionnement
de north stream 2 pourrait donc
faciliter les de l'état de l'europe
résoudre cette crise est-ce que vous
avez reçus depuis l'europe des signaux
qui permettrait de dire que la mise en
exploitation de ce gazoduc accélère
c'est le contraire on constate que les
barrières administratives ne sont
toujours pas levée qu'on nous pose des
questions par rapport à un troisième
paquet énergétique auquel est soumis ce
projet là du nord stream 2 et où
il existe un certain nombre de détails
que je veux pas évoquer ici
ces barrières existe administratives et
pour l'instant ils ne sont pas surmonter
ne sont pas levés
je sais que la société nord stream 2 est
en train de discuter défaire des
discussions avec les autorités
allemandes parce que c'est le régulateur
allemand qui doit adopter la décision
est pour l'instant cette décision n'est
pas prise et bien sûr que si nous
pouvons augmenter nos livraisons par ce
gazoduc
alors on pourrait dire
à 100% avec 100% de certitude que les
tensions
sur le marché et russes seraient
beaucoup moins importante ce qui bien
évidemment
conduirait à une diminution des prix du
gaz sur le marché européen mais encore
une fois les barrières administratives
n'ont pas encore la possibilité de faire
ceci
maintenant je voudrais passer la parole
à nos participants monsieur patrick
pouyanné merci beaucoup de nous
rejoindre vous êtes
dans le même bâtiment mais seulement
dans un local voisin dit s'il vous plaît
à quel point sont graves les
conséquences pour votre business et pour
l'europe dans son ensemble cette crise
gazière en europe merci beaucoup je suis
très content de me retrouver à moscou de
nouveau même pas dans votre salle mais
dans une autre salle je voudrais dire
tout d'abord que nous sommes confrontés
non pas une crise gazière en europe il
faut dire que tous les marchés gaziers
sont liés entre eux et nous voyons une
flambée de demande en chine par exemple
ans au japon mais aussi en corée
ceci est lié à une transition
énergétique qui est la tradition du
charbon vers le gaz c'est très bien et
nous le comprenons très bien nous
observons une augmentation de la demande
par exemple en chine
dans les ménages de appartenant à la
deuxième deuxième en seconde classe nous
classe moyenne je pense que le président
de la fédération de russie a
parfaitement raison nous produisons le
gazélec y fier nous sommes le deuxième
producteur du gaz rectifier
mais cette année là
à cause de la flambée de la demande on
peut dire que pratiquement tous les
volumes du gaz liquéfié produit par les
états unis ont été réorientés vers la
chine
la raison principale
qui explique
justement cette diminution du volume de
gaz en europe ce n'est pas depuis la
russie que la quantité de gaz a été
réduite c'est partir d'autres sources
encore une fois tous les marchés gaziers
sont liés entre eux on ne peut pas on ne
doit pas penser uniquement à l'idée de
la demande en europe mais il faut penser
à la demande dans toutes les régions du
monde et c'est la demande mondiale qui
augmente
pour le gaz y compris le gaz liquéfié
nous avons quelques 10% du marché
mondial du gnl et ces derniers temps
donc les chiffres montent et tous les
ans notre notre notre production
augmente de 10% à peu près
ne sont pas très contents des prix
élevés ce n'est pas mauvais non
seulement pour la société mais aussi
pour nos clients nous voulons développer
le système gazier notamment pour
remplacer par le gaz le charbon ce qui
pourrait bien évidemment contribuer à la
lutte contre le changement climatique
mais pour ce ca poursuit céline nous
avons besoin de
coup beaucoup moins élevé aujourd'hui le
charbon devient demandé parce que son
coût est inférieur nous avons besoin
d'une stabilité pour normaliser la
situation je voudrais dire aussi que la
plus grande partie des marchés gaziers
se basent aujourd'hui sur des contrats à
long terme à toutes à l'énergie
85%
sont réalisés au niveau de 9 à 10
$
pour des unités conventionnelles et non
pas 30 40 $ pour ses unités et
conventionnelles sur les marchés spots
nous devons bien comprendre la part des
contrats à long terme dans notre
activité beaucoup dépendre des facteurs
extérieurs bien évidemment notamment les
conditions météorologiques et si nous
allons avoir encore une fois l'hiver qui
serait froid donc peut-être ça va
préserver les prix à un niveau élevé
mais encore une fois ce n'est pas dans
l'intérêt des producteurs ce qui est
dans l'intérêt des producteurs c'est de
revenir à des prix plus bas et
nous devons convaincre nos clients
que normalement leur intérêt c'est de
voir des contrats à long terme qui
permet de rendre les prix plus
prévisible et plus stable
je pense qu'une autre laissant consiste
dans ce que plus
nous mettons en place des énergies non
renouvelables dans nos systèmes plus
nous créons des risques
parce que ces systèmes ne non pas deux
facteur permanent moins de pluie au
brésil en chine - devant en europe et
cela conduit tout de suite à la baisse
de la production d'énergie électrique
avec les énergies renouvelables il faut
avoir donc des réserves et donc nous
devons assurer des prix encore une fois
moins élevé ce serait dans l'intérêt de
tous merci beaucoup maintenant je
voudrais passer la parole à bernard lui
ni
nous entendons parler aujourd'hui tout
le temps des discussions et des
changements qui se produisent vendre
celle et ça peut conduire à ce que le
forage
un article ne sera plus pratique et et
que ce produit ne pourrait plus donc
avoir l'accès à marcher bien sûr que ça
va mais également donc influencer la
société comme total énergie et autres et
est ce que vous êtes préoccupé par ce
type de risque bonjour je suis moi aussi
très content d'être ici à moscou et je
vous remercie d'avoir été notre site
suscite et bp à participer à cette
conversation je pense que les prix écrit
ce que nous constatons en europe nous a
rappelés à nous tous s'il y avait besoin
de rappeler à qui que ce soit que le
secteur énergétique fait partie des
factures très importante qui est à sur
la fonctionnalité de la société et donc
le secteur énergétique se développe dans
la même direction c'est à dire depuis le
bas vers le haut si nous regardons les
conclusions clés de cette situation nous
pouvons parler d'eux
l'excès de d'espoir sur des énergies
renouvelables l'énergie doivent être
fiables et malheureusement le soleil ne
brille pas toujours le vent ne souffle
pas toujours et donc la question se pose
est-ce que les énergies renouvelables
est une source sûre de l'énergie il y a
aussi comme l'a dit patrick il ya une
combinaison de facteurs le manque de
pluie au brésil et ça a été un grand
choc pour les centrales hydroélectriques
il ya aussi donc les
informations de prix qui a fait que les
livraisons américains ont été réorientés
vers la chine et donc il ya toute une
série de facteurs qui
ont été combinées le temps froid en
avril et en mai en europe et ce qui a
fait que nous sommes dans la situation
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on a à faire je pense qu'il faut
faire des investissements investir en
quoi il faut investir dans des capacités
de réserve qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que nous devons investir dans
des contrats à long terme justement que
nous concluons dans le monde entier cela
signifie également l'incité d'investir
dans le gaz naturel parce que le gaz
naturel c'est un élément clé qui permet
d'équilibrer le système avec les
capacités de réserve c'est également la
nécessité
d'investir dans la structure des
réservoirs de gaz hélas nous avons eu
une diminution aussi et il faut investir
également dans la diversification des
différentes sources d'énergie pour avoir
un système intégral qui pourrait avoir
un taux de résilience bien donné c'est
un facteur 2
nécessaires pour assurer la vie de notre
société et c'est donc le principe sur
lequel nous ne basons notre
entreprise en ce qui concerne le forage
en apathique vous ne craignez pas ces
changements à réglementation européens
concernant ce problème bernard est ce
que vous êtes avec nous
donc nous voyons voir votre commentaire
par rapport à la modification de la
législation en matière de forages en
arctique je pense que nous on pensait
cette question là mais là donc ce qui
est un élément clé c'est la demande nous
faisons tout ce que nous pouvons par
rapport à la nécessité d'assurer la
livraison mais si les livraisons baisse
alors que la demande ne
baisse pas alors il y aura qu'une seule
condition la hausse des prix je ne veux
pas dire que aujourd'hui nous devons
prêter plus d'attention aux
consommateurs il est nécessaire de
comprendre que cette système c'est le
rapport entre l'offre et la demande et
donc les deux parties doivent travailler
de façon équilibrée si nous n'allons
agir que sur les réseaux magicien pas
sur la demande ne pourront pas
constituer un système stable au
contraire le système sera plus volatils
et le système qui devient plus volatil
ce n'est pas un système qui serait
optimal pour la société on a parlé de la
volatilité patrick a parlé de la chine
monsieur le président poutine avant vous
avez dit que la russie à la chine sont
d'accord sur beaucoup de points de vue
et ils ont des priorités communes au
niveau régional au niveau mondial je
voudrais poser la question suivante
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans cette situation parce que le
président scié a dit qu'il y a une tâche
historique par rapport à la situation
dans la région de la mer de chine
méridionale et cette mission consiste à
réunir la chine
si la chine donc veut envahir taiwan est
ce que vous voyez un risque de guerre
dans cette situation là
si vous avez suivi de façon attentive ce
que disent les dirigeants de la
république populaire de chine
vous avez entendu bien évidemment que
dans une de ses interventions dernière
et là j'ai assisté à cet événement je
pense qu'il s'agissait d'une événement
dans le cadre de l'union alors le
président ci a dit
que la chine
n'envisage pas d'utiliser les forces
armées pour la
la solution 2
quelques problèmes que ce soit à peu
près ça il a dit c'est le premier
élément et puis donc
à ma connaissance la philosophie
chinoise
et donc notamment en matière de la
construction d'états cette philosophie
n'est pas lui l usage de la force
troisième élément la chine n'a pas
besoin d'utiliser la force la chine est
une grande économie puissance et avec
la complicité de chat par parité donc la
chine est aujourd'hui la première
économie du monde en dépassant les états
unis en développant ses potentiels la
chine est parfaitement capable
de réaliser ses objectifs nationaux et
donc je n'y vois aucune menace en ce qui
concerne la merde le mer de chine
méridionale
c'est vrai qu'ils xts des intérêts et
qui sont orientés différemment et mais
notre position position de la fédération
de russie est la suivante nous devons
donner la possibilité à tous les pays de
la région sans intervention des pays qui
ne font pas partie de la région
calmement s'appuyant sur des normes
fondamentales du droit international par
la voie de négociations résoudre toutes
les questions qui peuvent surgir je
pense que c'est pendant ciel était
existe et c'est comme s'ils étaient ne
sont pas encore épuisés
merci monsieur le président quand à
votre réponse
3,5 milliards de dollars c'est le volume
du commerce qui transitent par la mer de
chine notamment le pétrole c'est donc
une question
internationale aussi lorsque vous parlez
de non ingérence des autres pays vous
parlez des états unis je parle des pays
qui ne sont pas dans les régions sont
pas situés dans la région
si l'on regarde cette
situation d'une manière plus large le
président xi a pris des mesures
importantes pour résoudre le problème de
la crise énergétique les écolos de la
chine va acheter le gaz à tout prix la
question était de savoir si la chine
peut également avoir des capacités pour
correspondre aux l'agenda vert qui elle
est donc le danger si si la chine
renonce à l'agenda vert cotait vous me
posez la question avec je veux pas
répondre je suis président russe n'ont
pas président chinois je ne sais pas ce
que prévoit là les dirigeants de la
chine je sais ce qu'ils font en
compétition avec nous c'est notre
partenaire commercial le plus important
malgré une baisse dans l'économie
mondiale le chiffre d'affaires entre la
russie et la chine augmente à dépasser
les 100 milliards de la sur le neuf mois
de l'année en cours pour nous la chine
est donc un partenaire extrêmement
fiable je ne parle pas de la composante
politique je sais tu un partenaire
stratégique
dans tous les domaines pratiquement
la chine est partenaire fiable
rempli ses engagements si des questions
emparés ces questions économiques
notamment leur nous réunissons autour de
la table et nous cherchons ensemble des
solutions et notre trouvant
solution par la voie du compromis
ceci concerne également la coopération
énergétique
la chine travaille avec nous sur l'un
des plus grands projets lng compassion
avec total et novatek notamment
d'ailleurs c'est un projet qui a du
succès le projet arctique el hadji en
arctique le deuxième projet
la chine y prendra part également je
pense nous avons
construit
le gazoduc vers la chine le volume total
auquel on veut arriver 7,38 milliards de
mètres cubes chine est un marché
croissant l'énorme marché nous sommes en
train de développer une somme
pratiquement d'accord sur l'itinéraire
de le deuxième isner et revit à la
mongolie
quand la livraison du charbon
génération électrique à partir de
charbon en chine est importante mais les
dirigeants chinois
prennent des mesures maintenant pour
réduire cette génération à partir du
charbon il y à 1,5 milliard de personnes
qui vivent en chine c'est difficile donc
mais ils le font il y a une feuille de
route pour réduire l'émission de co2 ça
concerne également le projet
d'augmenter l'utilisation de ce
combustible de transition à savoir le
gaz et nous sommes en train de
travailler là dessus je ne sais pas si
tous les objectifs seront réalisés que
tous les objectifs que la chine s'est
posée parce que le volume de ces
engagements est un énorme mais jusqu'à
présent tout ce que nous avons réalisé
avec la chine pour arriver
tout ce que les chinois ont fait pour
réaliser leurs objectifs tout a été mis
en place ils ont tous réalisé raison
arrivé à leurs objectifs ceci nous donne
l'espoir
que quant à la réduction de la charge
anthropogène sur l'environnement la
chine pourrait bien arriver à un
objectif à l'horizon 2060 objectif que
la chine s'est posée
c'est à dire que nous pouvons bien
espère que la chine y arrivera d'accord
je m'adresse à aulas calais news
pourriez vous
partager votre vision
technologique comment est ce que la
technologie nous permettront de lutter
contre le changement climatique
nous venons d'avoir un rapport de
l'agencé nationale de l'énergie réduire
de trois fois l'impact sur la nature
quelle est la stratégie de votre
entreprise notamment dans le domaine des
véhicules électriques au jour quant
à l'automobile cette ce secteur
traverse une transformation importante
pour arriver à l'émission zéro je vais
dire deux mots sur les technologies sur
les innovations les progrès dont le
véhicule électrique dans les capacités
des batteries et bien ces progrès sont
impressionnants
la compétitivité des technologies
augmente et nous sommes sur ces
technologies
remplaceront les moteurs à combustion
interne
assez rapidement et donc notre secteur
va également changer ensuite le cadre
légal pensons notamment à l'accord de
paris sur le changement climatique la
plupart depuis ils ont ratifié dans pour
notre secteur pour daimler pour mercedes
benz ceux ci veut dire que nous devons
arriver aux émissions zéro
en 2030 même avant le terme posés par la
cour de paris mais sur des éléments
extrêmement importants
c'est la question du capital pour
l'industrie automobile il sera est très
difficile d'attirer le capital
de la part d'attirer les investisseurs à
long terme si
les secours doivent ils n'arrivent pas à
montrer un
plan de réduction des émissions ils nous
demandent les émissions ne demandent un
plan hydrogène un plan réduction des
émissions si vous n'êtes pas persuasif
les mesures ne vont pas investir tout
simplement quant à la vitesse de
l'application de ces technologies il
faut que les gouvernements et les
entreprises travaillent ensemble il faut
développer des structures parce que sans
des infrastructures on ne pourra pas
changer l'économie mondiale pour passer
aux véhicules électriques
les stations de charge sept sièges sujet
important créé cette structure
et puis la question est de se voir
à quel point ce passage sera rapide et à
quel point cette source d'énergie
renouvelable
soucieux vertes seront disponibles si
vous me posiez cette question il ya
trois ans ma réponse aurait été beaucoup
plus sceptiques beaucoup plus
conservatrice aujourd'hui j'ai changé
d'avis quant aux entreprises de mobiles
de luxe mercedes-benz notamment nous
pouvons nous développer plus rapidement
que le marché la moyenne du marché merci
je voudrais poser la question sur le
marché du pétrole monsieur le président
est ce que le pétrole arrivera à 100 $
pour par baril probablement c'est tout à
fait possible
le pétrole augmente
les prix du pétrole augmentent en
parlant de la russie
de la partenaire dans l'opep plus nous
faisons tout pour que pour stabiliser le
marché du pétrole pour éviter des bons
des prix les flambées des prix souci
n'est pas dans nos intérêts nous
respectons nos engagements
liés notamment à la réduction de
l'extraction de la production ce sont
des solutions qui sont difficiles à
prendre pour nous pour nos entreprises
parce que à la différence des autres
bassins être les fers
moyen-orient notamment
notre production se déroule dans des
conditions climatiques difficiles pour
réduire donc la production il faut ou
des
prendre des mesures spéciales qui coûte
nous avons nous l'avons fait nous avons
stabilisé le marché un rôle important
positif a été jouée par le prince
héritier de ça vous dit pas le roi
saoudite et par l'ancien président
américain monsieur donald trump jour le
dit d'une manière très responsable parce
que j'ai participé à ces
négociations
triangulaire il luttait pour les
intérêts de 16 ans nos pistes des
entreprises américaines les états unis
n'ont pas participé à ce travail
directement
opep plus mais les états
unis
tout en pensant aux intérêts des
entreprises américaines ils ont
influencé le processus c'était une
influence positive nous avons pu
stabiliser le marché et notamment sauvé
des emplois aux etats unis le marché
s'est stabilisé ne sommes pas encore
arrivés au niveau d'avant la crise 11
millions de barils par jour notre
position
d'augmenter la production en suivant les
besoins du marché mes collègues sont
réunis ici les dirigeants des
entreprises russes nous
prenons en considération des intérêts
jeu nationale mais aussi les intérêts de
nos entreprises grandes entreprises nous
communiquons avec eux bourdonnant ses
efforts que nous avons réduit donc la
production mais ceux ci étaient
bénéfiques pour le marché mondial qui
s'est stabilisé les prix ont augmenté et
ont atteint des
chiffres
voulue les bénéfices de nos entreprises
on se sont amélioré également et le
budget a également gagné c'était gagné
en gagnant nous ne voulons pas contenir
la production pour avoir une flambée des
prix énormes comme sur le marché gazier
en ce moment nous sommes pour une
évolution lente et équilibrée
monsieur le président j'ai entendu
dire que le président tente vous a
appelé en personne et la discuter des
prix du pétrole ou discuter des
problématiques autour de plus est ce que
le président byden vous a contacté en
tant que représentant d'un peu plus non
nous n'avons pas discuté directement ces
questions nous sommes en contact avec
l'administration américaine des états
unis j'ai des relations stables
relations de travail avec le président
maiden
la secrétaire d'état adjointe des états
unis et à moscou en ce moment elle
discute avec collègues russes le
problème de non les projets de nos
contacts
futur avec le président bridel nous
avons des relations constructives avec
l'administration à washington
quarante quatre
pour cent de leurs aides publiques à à
aux états unis d'après les sondages
veulent revoir donald trump aux
élections américaines dans quelques
années qui sont les vôtres vision
écouter ça cela ne concerne pas je veux
pas donner des évaluations avant
l'élection de tram attrait élections
avant les dernières élections j'ai
toujours répété nous allons travailler
avec le président des états unis qui
sera élu pas le peuple américain nous
nous donnons pas d'évaluation l'intérêt
fondamental des deux états dans le
domaine de la sécurité
réduction des armes stratégiques
lutte contre le terrorisme contre le
blanchiment
contre les
les shows tout ceci cet objectif c'est
les paradis fiscaux tout ceci cet
objectif tout ceci permettra d'établir
de bonnes relations et que
la l'élite
à politique américaine arrêtera j'espère
cette spéculation au niveau des
relations avec la russie au détriment
des entreprises américaines
par exemple les sanctions américaines
dans le domaine athlétique qui est laid
le résultat exxon mobil a abandonné des
contrats très profitable notamment en
extrême orient qui a gagné qui est le
gagnant
seulement les prix du gaz ont flambé sur
le qui tu peux être la situation est
telle que les américains eux mêmes
souffrent le résultat c zéro et même
celle rutan négatif pour ceux qui le
font
cette politique n'a pas de perspective
je pense qu'on va prendre conscience de
cela que nous pourrons rétablir une
relation progressivement
merci et maintenant je voudrais
m'adresser à darren woods sommes
monsieur vous nous avons discuté des
investissements nous avons dit il faut
des investissements dans le secteur
pétrolier et gazier nous avons vu le
rapport de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie qui dit qu'il faut investir
non seulement dans l'énergie verte mais
aussi dans le pétrole et le gaz pourrait
assurer un passage souple nous sommes en
train de détruire la demande peut-être
bonjour
je suis très content de participer à ce
forum même par visioconférence
nous en avons beaucoup parlé
avec le président notamment il est
nécessaire d'assurer un équilibre
nous voudrions diminuer le niveau des
émissions et en plus l'énergie c'est
quelque chose dont tout le monde a
besoin dans le monde entier donc
l'énergie va poursuivre de jouer son
rôle très important dans
l'épanouissement des étapes et quand il
s'agit du marché
gazo pétrolier je peux préciser que nous
tous nous produisons ce type de produits
nous
livrons s'est produit à nos clients et
donc il ne serait ni il est nécessaire
d'assurer la stabilité du marché et si
nous y parvenons donc il faudrait
poursuivre les investissements dans la
production est un des défis auxquels
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui comme
le monde entier sait que
le plus grand fournisseur du gaz et du
pétrole
sur le marché
fait face à des problèmes très
importants à cause de dukan est russe et
donc des investissements
est orienté vers
la nécessité de reconstitution des
stocks dont kg mais il est maintenant
nécessaire d'assurer cette sortie du coc
vie de 19 je pense que lyon toute
l'histoire du développement du secteur
énergétique
les prix augmentaient toujours et cela
stimule et
l arrivée de nouveaux investissements et
quand il s'agit de secteurs qui
utilisent beaucoup d'énergie donc il
s'agit à vous il s'agit donc avant tout
de la lutte visant à réduire les prix
ils insistèrent sur l équilibre entre
l'offre et la demande sur les marchés
énergétiques différentes décisions sont
prises au niveau des pays différents il
ya des gouvernements qui est
h2
d'atteindre la réduction
par rapport au volume du gaz et du
pétrole et dans l'avenir nous pourrons
arriver à ce que bernard a évoqué dans
son intervention
nous allons arriver à
renforcement de la volatilité et à
l'aggravation des déséquilibres et ce
sera un très grand défi pour tout le
monde nous devons travailler ensemble
mais déjà
nous avons des principes nécessaires et
une volonté politique pour ceux ci
qui vont contribuer à l'amélioration de
la qualité de vie des gens et qui vont
assurer également la transition
énergétique vers des énergies plus
propres ce qui a déjà été écrit ce qui
déjà a été évoquée par les participants
la discussion d'aujourd'hui
je voudrais maintenant
demander à patrick
la chose suivante est-ce qu'il est
difficile de prendre ces décisions là
est ce que cela va demander des
milliards de dollars est-ce que ça va
demander plusieurs années par exemple
aux états unis il y à un changement d
administration et chaque nouvelle
administration donc apporte un nouveau
programme économique vous en tant que
partenaire des états unis qu'est ce que
vous pouvez dire et j'ai pas seulement
des états unis les etats unis c'est un
pays dans lequel nous produisons de
l'énergie et c'est un pays dans lequel
nous investissons
est le véritable défi pour nous tous
c'est ce que
l'énergie aujourd'hui c'est
le présent de notre planète et 50%
c'est la production
du pétrole et du gaz' indiquent que nous
devons poursuivre les investissements
pour pourvoir notre population à
l'énergie parce que la population en a
besoin en même temps nous devons
accélérer le développement pour donc
aller du côté du
refus des sources fossiles
je parle bien évidemment des énergies
renouvelables et c'est ce que nous
faisons au niveau de notre société total
énergie non seulement nous avons changé
de nom pour montrer que nous faisons
cela mais pour vous dire que 60 % de non
frais parents se rend donc réorienter
vers les énergies renouvelables et pour
nous le gaz va contribuer à cette
transition énergétique
en même temps 20 5%
seront orientés vers la création de
nouvelles productions au niveau de notre
société notamment en utilisant les
énergies renouvelables nous voyons que
les stratégies peuvent d être
différentes dans des pays différents
mais malgré ceci tous encouragent les
investissements dans les énergies
renouvelables à notre objectif est de
faire partie du top 5 des sociétés qui
produisent de l'énergie à base d
énergies renouvelables j'espère que nous
pourrons atteindre cet objectif
même dans les pays producteurs
comme par exemple l'irak on lance des
projets
pour l'utilisation de gaz
et donc l'utilisation également de
l'énergie solaire donc cela veut dire
que les pipes pourrait
compenser ce déficit auxquels nous
sommes confrontés aujourd'hui
en matière énergétique
cette stratégie qui consiste à trouver
un équilibre
c'est la chose c'est l'idée qui est
souvent évoquée aujourd'hui par des
organisations internationales de
l'énergie
au fait on nous appelle à arrêter des
investissements dans la production d
énergie à base du pétrole et de passer
aux gaz et aux énergies renouvelables
mais en même temps il faut continuer
d'investir dans le pétrole et du gaz
parce que nous voyons qu'il ya
une baisse de production
la demande de baisse il s'agit de 3 4%
après la pandémie la demande commencent
à augmenter et sinon ne remplissons pas
cette lacune entre la demande naturelle
et la demande est réelle donc les coûts
vont poursuivre leur hausse ce n'est pas
dans l'intérêt des consommateurs il faut
investir suffisamment de fonds dans
l'énergie dans le secteur énergétique du
présent et investir dans le secteur
énergétique du futur
je pense que ce que vous venez de dire
est lié en partie
à ce qui a été dit par monsieur
abdelaziz g poutine si on parle des
engagements de la russie en matière de
l'agenda du climat je voudrais vous
poser la question suivante est ce que
vous allez participer à la conférence
cop 26 je n'ai pas pris la décision pour
l'instant
à cause de la pandémie bien évidemment
mais dans tous les cas je vais
participer à ces travaux ça c'est sûr
je ne sais pas si je vais y aller
physiquement pour l'instant je n'ai pas
pris ma décision mais je vais y
participer sans aucun doute
vous avez peur d'attraper le coc vide
je vais déjà une situation dans laquelle
je pouvais être contaminé par le vide en
communiquant avec mes proches collègues
qui malheureusement eux
sont tombés malades du cog hill mais
cela
finalement je ne suis pas tombé malade
grâce justement aux vaccins scouts nick
v mais ça ne me concerne pas moi parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
m'accompagnent dans ce type de voyage
peut-être plus d'une centaine de
personnes les journalistes le service du
presse le service de garde les membres
du service de protocole donc il ya un
grande nombre de personnes qui d'une
façon ou d'une autre prenne ce risque là
et donc il ya là il ya une matière à
réflexion
j'ai passé deux semaines dans la
quarantaine donc je comprends ce que
c'est nous avons parlé des engagements
de la russie
beaucoup disent que la russie ne fait
pas assez pour devenir un pays à carbone
zéro car et à tous le berg a dit
récemment
par rapport à
0 2e pays que c'était du bla bla bla il
faut vous voir sans clichés sincérité
politique la situation réelle
vous avez vous avez parlé de la
disponibilité de la russie d'augmenter
les raisons des sources énergétiques
dans le monde et dans un europe vous
voulez que nous augmentions ça ou non
mais puisque vous voulez que nous
mettions notre livraison donc il faut
que nous produisions cela
l'électricité et le n'est pas dans la
prise il faut voir une source municipale
d'énergie et donc nous devons produire
des ressources énergétiques pour pouvoir
satisfaire les besoins du marché non
seulement nous avons augmenté les
raisons du gaz mais nous avons également
augmenté de 8% les livraisons du charbon
vers le marché mondial dans les deux
directions
vers l'est et vers l'ouest
donc nous avons augmenté la production
et de quelques 8 5% et nous avons
augmenté donc que nos exportations de 8%
que je viens de le dire
regardons maintenant notre mix
énergétique
26% dans ce mix c'est l'énergie
nucléaire 20% c'est l'énergie
hydroélectrique 40% c'est le gaz
donc il s'agit là donc de mix qui est un
très bas niveau carbone
86 %
le mix presque aussi propre et celui des
états unis là où ce chiffre est de 77%
en allemagne fédérale
ce chiffre est de 64%
sauf que cette part propre dans le mix
énergétique
donc notre mix énergétique est le plus
propre enfin un des plus propres dans le
monde et nous poursuivons nos efforts en
vue de
d'assurer la neutralité carbone d'ici
2060 et comme d'ailleurs
nombre d'autres pays nous sommes prêts à
le faire nous avons des projets qui ont
déjà été établis pour atteindre cet
objectif
nous avons déjà établi des préférences
fiscales pour les entreprises et les
secteurs qui vont
s'atteler à la réalisation de ces tâches
c'est à dire la démission des émissions
des gaz à effet serre y compris dans le
cadre des énergies renouvelables y
compris dans le cadre de l'énergie à
hydrogène
donc nous avons tout un nombre de
programmes et des stimuli fiscaux
je pense que
la russie ne fait pas que faire des
déclarations officielles mais elles
avancent de façon préférée elle dans
cette fois là bien sûr que
nous comprenons très bien que le mépris
pour ces question de la préservation de
l'environnement peut être nocive non
seulement pour notre pays mais pour le
monde entier parce que je viens de le
dire au début de mon intervention que le
réchauffement climatique
va beaucoup plus vite dans notre région
par exemple un article bien dans la
région où il ya du permafrost donc nous
y pensons beaucoup et nous y travaillons
beaucoup vous avez parlé de l'énergie
nucléaire à plusieurs reprises dans
votre mot d'introduction et après pensez
vous que les gouvernements allemands et
des autres pays font une erreur à
renoncer à au nucléaire non je ne veux
pas utiliser ce type de termes je ne
voudrais accuser personne comme on le
fait d'habitude par rapport à un autre
pays et c'est un fondement et à chaque
occasion et riopa erreur ce sont les
citoyens de l'allemagne qui doivent dire
cela
je viens de dire que nous avons 20 %
dans notre
21 % de l'énergie nucléaire dans notre
mix énergétique
si je dit autre chose donc je me suis
trompé parce que 20 6% c'est la part de
l'énergie l'énergie
hydraulique donc l'allemagne fédérale a
pris la décision de renoncer au
nucléaire je ne peux pas dire si c'est
une erreur au nom
mais je pense que ça n'a pas beaucoup de
sens parce que
le piqué voisins
de l'allemagne à la france à la part
du nucléaire dans le mix qui était ce
qui s'élève à 80 % à quoi sert ferme et
tes propres centrales atomiques alors
que ton voisin à l'énergie et le secteur
d'énergie nucléaire qui se développe
très rapidement
peut-être par rapport à un pays aussi
grand que la russie sur le plan du
territoire on peut à dire que par
exemple dans une partie on abandonne le
nucléaire dans d'autres parts dans une
autre partie on continue à le développer
mais en europe tout est prêt
les états sont prêts des autres soit on
doit penser à une politique à l'échelle
européen soit sa perte ou le sens
mais toutes les façons je ne me souviens
pas mais
donc le mix énergétique est très bon en
allemagne monsieur barnier est là donc
il doit connaître mieux la chose que moi
en allemagne
quelle est la part du nucléaire 2
une clé r aujourd'hui 11% alors qu'avant
c'était plus de 30%
c'était la part du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique
bien sûr qu'il s'agit d'une réduction
très importante
et qui doit être remplacé par quelque
chose qu'on pensait par quelque chose
mais compensait par quoi par les
éoliennes
mais écoutez
c'est pas logique et ça provoque à
l'augmentation de prix tout à fait de
façon tranquille de façon équilibrée de
façon rythmique et si vous voulez
donc et puis les décisions doivent être
prises par les professionnels j'ai
appris récemment que une
cours hollandaise a pris une décision
par rapport à la société shell quelle
était cette décision
par la décision de ce tribunal
shell a été
du mans en a demandé à shell de réduire
de 45 % les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est un précédent qui qui n'a pas
de sens si les gens qui ne sont pas
professionnellement préparés ils vont
prendre des décisions de ce type là donc
et bien sûr qu'il ya des flambées des
prix dans les marchés au moyen âge
lorsque les eaux hollande s était
confronté à d
à des hivers plus froide donc les les
hollandais faisait beaucoup du patin sur
leur canot et toujours ils ont donc ce
sport qui est de se développer donc si
ça va continuer comme ça peut-être ils
vont donc poursuivre cette pratique du
matin pour aller d'un voisin à l'autre
et non seulement pour aller d'un point a
à un point b mais pour se réchauffer
tout simplement et donc les parties vous
l'été du marché d'aujourd'hui disent que
ce risque existe il faut que dans ce
domaine les décisions soient prises par
les professionnels bien sûr en contact
avec les organisations non
gouvernementales avec l'opinion publique
qui doivent
contrôler de façon très strict tout ce
qui se passe dans cette sphère là qu'ils
doivent
dire aux sociétés aux gouvernements un
de d'avancer dans la bonne direction
parce que
l'avenir de l'humanité tout entière de
pendu
du réchauffement climatique donc mais
aujourd'hui beaucoup de décisions sont
prises
en partant de la conjoncture politique
actuelle je pense que
un très grand nombre de ceux qui nous
parlent de
céder ses préoccupations
exploite donc les peurs et les craintes
de la population
mais toutes les façons il y a des aussi
des contraintes pour la production de
l'énergie par des sources dit les
propres il faut que les gens il faut que
les associations y compris associations
écologiques puisse voir tous ces
problèmes et pour qu'il puisse prendre à
tête reposée
effectivement si l'on parle de ce
passage souple je voudrais bien poser la
question sur le cadre légal européen
qui interdit notamment le forage en
optique dans les régions arctiques
production peut être la gazon interdite
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
erreur parce que l'économie russe va en
souffrir
vous voyez si cette décision provoque
des flambées des prix la russie ne va
pas tellement souffrir nous allons
réduire la production mais les prix vont
nous permettre
de regagner cette somme il ne faut pas
que les décisions
pareilles soient prises sur le plan
politique uniquement il faut assurer le
contact avec les professionnels avec les
experts dans ce domaine
ainsi l'équilibré nécessaire entre
l'énergie verte et l'énergie
traditionnelle pourrait être trouvée non
pas au détriment des consommateurs n'ont
pas au détriment des gens jeu déjà dit
nous nous sommes en train de m'en parler
tous ces prix font souffrir qui les gens
les gens les consommateurs
notamment les prix du gaz à l'intérieur
de la russie pour les ménages sont
d'environ
64 dollars pour mille mètres cubes pour
les industries
64 ans
ne s'est pas
1200 comme les prix spot en europe
ceci permet d'organiser un travail
rythmé de l'économie à la fin cette
année nous pouvons nous pourrons
j'espère constaté une croissance soit
corps de bébé il ya bien sûr des
problèmes mais cette flambée de prix
créé des problèmes or là le
développement souple permet aux gens de
d'avoir des projets regardez l'europe de
l'est regarde l europe de l'ouest tous
les mois on augmente les tarifs
communaux en ukraine notamment il ya une
forte augmentation
parce que vous avez maintenant en
ukraine
280 et un dollar pour 1000 cube le
revenu moyen
en ukraine de 200 et quelques dollars
par personne ça ne correspond pas du
tout et
c'est vrai qu'il y a des régions en
ukraine qui refuse de conclure des
contrats pour acheter des surcharges
boutique parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent
pour payer si on fait preuve d'une
approche mal équilibré ça va créer de
nouveaux problèmes au lieu de résoudre
des problèmes existants
en parlant de l' approche équilibrée
je voudrais vous poser la question est
ce que vous êtes satisfait du niveau de
soutien du de la part du gouvernement
britannique notamment
au début de la crise boris johnson était
en vacances notamment connais je pense
que le gouvernement britannique peuvent
ce qu'il fait est peu ce fait ce qu'il
peut les situations qu'on en europe
en grande bretagne c'est un problème
global ce n'est pas un problème régional
c'est un problème global qui est a
surgit brusquement
ce problème soudain à cause des de la
situation qui s'est créée c'est ça le
fonctionnement du marché il y avait ces
conditions qui étaient réunis pour faire
de sorte
que la le système s'est retrouvé dans
l'état actuel
en europe et en grande-bretagne
royaume uni nous appliquons des efforts
tout le monde applique des efforts pour
répondre à ce défi et ce n'est pas une
crise domestique c'est le résultat d'une
crise mondiale
nous avons déjà dit qu'il faut des
investissements des contrats long terme
qui est faut investir dans les
réservoirs à gaz il faut investir dans
l'extraction de gaz naturel il faut
augmenter le rôle du gaz naturel dans le
mix énergétique
et bien sûr nous allons
en tirer des leçons prochainement dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent
darren la même question que je voudrais
ça avoue ce qu'on parle des
investissements long terme il s'agit de
milliards de dollars sur plusieurs
années
nous savons qu'il faut regarder soucis
en perspective à long terme
l' agence
internationale de l'énergie l'a dit
notamment est-ce que c'est difficile
pour vous
d'en penser lorsqu'il est le changement
de l'administration 30 contre ben laden
nous avons vu notamment une approche qui
a changé radicalement d'une
administration à l'autre
vous avez tout à fait raison nous
opérons dans un milieu très difficile vu
les cycles et qui existent notre
planification et en dehors des
termes d'une administration d'intérim
présidentielle nous planifions à long
terme nous pensons au passage
énergétique nous pensons aux changements
technologiques
tout ceci se décide à long terme nous
sommes prêts à travailler avec toute
administration qui accède au pouvoir
quant à la politique qui nous permet
d'arriver à ces objectifs est de
répondre aux
demandes de la part du site et demande
pour des émissions réduites et en même
temps la demande d'une énergie
accessible nous pouvons effectivement
réfléchir il faut il faut il faut
réfléchir
il faut continuer à investir dans les
sources traditionnelles de l'énergie
mais il faut également
répondre aux besoins de la population
à l'époque de la transition énergétique
il faut qu'on mette
l'accent sur les fournisseurs qui
devrait fournir à des prix abordables
il faut que nos
fournisseurs nous fournissent à des prix
abordables
il faut augmenter le nombre de
partenaires faut pas se concentrer
uniquement sur le gouvernement
ou sur le privé il faut travailler avec
les universités avec l'association pour
voir l'avenir de cette transition
énergétique
nous essayons de modifier le système le
système qui est
difficile qui est compliqué comment
arriver à nos objectifs sans causer de
dommages à la société aux gens
comment est-ce que nous distribuons
notre capital c'est ça la question il
faut soutenir bien sûr avant tout les
technologies qui seront ne seront pas
cher mais qui assureront des émissions
réduites
nous sommes en train de d'essayer de
trouver des solutions
aulas lorsque vous pensez à l'avenir de
daimler de mercedes-benz
est-ce que puisque nous venons
d'avoir le rapport de la banque mondiale
qui dit que les emplois sont menacés
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'avenir de
votre
entreprise est ce que cette production
de véhicules électriques va
effectivement augmenté aussi rapidement
que vous avez prévu oui effectivement
lorsqu'on passe du moteur à combustion
interne aux
véhicules électriques bien sûr le nombre
d'emplois se réduire mais il ya d'autres
volets de nos activités qui qui augmente
nous investissons dans les
technologies informatiques notamment et
puis nous allons
réduire notre trace
argentique nous allons fournir aux gens
d emploi dans d'autres secteurs je pense
que nous allons réussir cette transition
énergétique quentin 2039 eh bien
effectivement nous avons décidé
de
modifier la construction de nos voitures
après 2025 il nous ne produirons que des
voitures électriques nous avons déjà
un cahier de charges nous avons un
emploi de temps qui nous
permet de prévoir la distribution de nos
ressources technologiques
génie c'est patrick une question sur
l'arctique ce que lorsque vous parlez du
permafrost du dégel de l'activisme
climatique
effectivement nous assistons à une
cacophonie totale j'ai
demande de responsabilité de la part des
entreprises pétrolières et gazières est
ce que ça complique doit tous travailler
notamment
lorsque il ya des occidentaux qui
considère la russie comme un mauvais
partenaire comme un fart un partenaire
non fiables d'abord nous avons établi un
très bon dialogue avec toutes les
parties à mon avis la meilleure solution
ceux de vos invités viser tout le monde
pour visiter notre usine nous avons
construit ensemble avec novatek dans la
région arctique nous avons des mêmes
normes pour la protection de
l'environnement pour la stabilité de
notre
de nos industries pour la sécurité au
travail
et surtout en parlant de l'afrique
effectivement nous avons nous total nous
avons fait des engagements repris les
engagements de ne pas extraire du
pétrole notamment parce que si vous avez
le déversement de pétrole se seraient
catastrophiques pour l'arctique il n'ya
pas question d'extraire le pétrole pour
la diversité biologique notamment nous
avons publié les résultats de nos
recherches nous avons fait des
recherches là dessus et nous allons
appliquer les meilleures normes pour la
préservation de la biodiversité
et pour nous pensons également aux
populations autochtones
c'est une approche très émotionnel
effectivement envers le
l'environnement il faut bien construire
un shih des priorités
l'un des facteurs clé effectivement
c'est de bien établir la hiérarchie des
tâches mais nous ne voulons pas faire
des exceptions
nous ne voulons pas non plus réduire la
fabrication de l'énergie en général
exxonmobil bp et nous toutes les grandes
entreprises énergétiques il faut qu'on
continue à produire de l'énergie mais
d'une façon durable et conformément aux
normes ceci est applicable à la russie
notamment si nous avons un financement
externe de la part des chances des
organismes de crédit bien nous
il faut dire pour investir les
investisseurs veulent
qu'on observe les normes sg il faut pas
mélanger ces deux sujets il faut bien
voir quels les situations sur place in
situ il faut voir quelle est notre
réaction il faut qu'on
soit conforme à notre principal
engagement c'est de réduire notre
empreinte
notre empreinte carbone et pour tous les
projets nous voulons bien sûr nous
pensons toujours à la bio diversité
c'est pas nous d'ailleurs qui évolueront
les résultats sont des experts externes
indépendants
la transition est donc une tâche très
importante
faire changer l'équilibré énergétique
c'est une tâche difficile
la transition énergétique c'est un
problème
difficile il ne faut pas qu'ils que de
nouveaux conflits apparaissent
il faut qu'on réussisse ensemble pour le
bien de tous cette transition
il faut pas être trop émotionnelles il
faut pas avoir que le noir et le blanc
il faut trouver des compromis il faut
trouver des moyens pour améliorer nos
normes nos pratiques on n'est pas
l'idéal on est on est prêt à écouter on
est prêt à écouter les ong les experts
on ne demande pas des exceptions pour
nous nous voulons que la planète soit
préservé
monsieur le président poutine vous venez
de dire que vont pas sûr de dalles et
physiquement à la coupe 26 mais quelle
est pour vous la structure des
changements climatiques sur le petit
politique ce sera une sorte des nations
unies climatique
lorsque tous les pays
pratiquent une politique climatique
comment donc ça va fonctionner dans
l'avenir selon vous
donc vous voulez savoir quels seront les
mécanismes de droit international auquel
mécanisme souhaité créer
d'abord
du point de vue de la production du
pétrole
et des nos exportations je pense que
nous avons des relations très
constructive avec les pays de l'opep est
le mécanisme qui est créée c'est à dire
le peuple +7 mécanisme qui travaillent
de façon efficace dans l'intérêt de
l'ensemble du secteur
internationale et mondiale
je pense donc
après
que la production puisse atteindre le
niveau d'avant la crise nous allons
poursuivre ce travail
y compris dans le cadre de l'agenda vert
c'est à dire que nous allons parler de
nouvelles technologies de production et
de l'utilisation des hydrocarbures nous
allons parler d'eux
la transition vers l'hydrogène et vers
d'autres énergies renouvelables ces
premiers éléments deuxièmement nous
avons donc
une rassemblement des producteurs de gaz
qui se situe au niveau international et
au sein duquel nous pouvons travailler
de façon très efficace il ya aussi le
g20 qui peut être très actif dans
l'enceinte des nations unies
mais les nations unies bien évidemment
doivent constituer bien une des plates
formes
essentielles pour la discussion des
questions climatiques non seulement pour
dire que la situation mauvaise mais pour
savoir qu'est ce que ce que nous pouvons
faire pour que soient assurées les
intérêts de l'économie et des gens et
pour que les conditions nécessaires soit
créée pour le développement de
l'économie verte
lorsque par exemple
les producteurs d automobiles
sont obligés à passer à la construction
d la production des voitures électriques
ok c'est bon parce que
les transports automobile c'est un des
pollueurs les plus importants mais
quelle est la source première
encore une fois l'électricité ça ne
vient pas de la prise du coran si en
allemagne dans le mix énergétique
il ya
33 à
35% du charbon
qui est la plus polluante par rapport
aux émissions de co2 donc on peut
produire
un nombre de thons mobile électrique
qu'on veut mais la production de
l'électricité art décentration des
centrales à charbon ça a peut donc
influencer sur la l'augmentation des
émissions par ce qui concerne la
responsabilité
comment nous pouvons donc
responsabiliser et différents
gouvernements comment ils peuvent donc
rendre compte par rapport à
l'exécution de leurs engagements comme
par exemple la chine aux autres comment
on peut faire que le gouvernement soit
responsabilité par rapport à leurs
engagements bien sûr que les gouvernants
doivent rendre compte à l'intérieur de
leur pays
au moment de la mise au point des
standards unique de comportement aussi
cela doit être atteint seulement dans
l'écart ou les décisions seront
équitables justes
si ces préoccupations qui sont les
préoccupations du monde entier par
rapport aux changements climatiques si
ça ne fait pas partie ça ne fera pas
l'objet des spéculations
si sous le slogan de la préservation de
la nature et il n'y a pas de personne
qui va
rechercher des avantages concurrentiels
si nous mettons au point et si nous
mettons en place des approches
transparent pour la prise de décision
finale alors donc nous pouvons dire que
nous avançons dans la bonne direction
en ce qui concerne donc cet agenda
climatique et sinon il y aura toujours
des déséquilibres conte sur le marché
gazier en europe aujourd'hui et la
situation ne changera pas vers le mieux
en matière du climat non plus
selon vous
est-ce que c'est politique et régulière
en matière climatique aux états unis et
en europe
est-ce que ça a un impact sur les
discussions qui sont menées au niveau de
le paix peu plus par exemple ou bien de
l'opep ce que nous voyons ce que nous
entendons aujourd'hui dans l'union
européenne par rapport à ces c'est un
pot carbone ça suscite des
préoccupations parce que si les
décisions sont prises de façon
unilatérale et si nous voyons que c'est
un moyen de la lutte concurrentielles
déloyales donc il y aura le même
résultat que aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que les prix vont augmenter tout
simplement comment on fait les
américains ils ont quitté le marché
europe 1 ils ont réduit leurs ventes de
moitié
ils ont donc réduit de 14 milliards de
mètres cubes alors livraison d'un gué
c'est tout si donc les décisions qui
sont prises sont inadéquats
alors donc nous allons
avoir une réaction appropriée il y a
bien évidemment des avantages
concurrentiels pour la russie à cause
d'eux
ces réserves importantes des
hydrocarbures oui bien sûr mais ce sont
nos avantages concurrentiels
naturel
sais tu sais quelque chose qui qui
constitue une des données d éducation
faut pas mettre au point des mécanismes
pour
chercher à
limiter l'action de ces avantages
naturels il faut mener un dialogue
honnête et ouvert et nous y sommes prêts
monsieur
le président poutine je voudrais donc
exprimer surtout de mécontentement ce
qui concerne de vos partenaires
européen qu'est ce que l'europe peut
faire peur rapport pour pouvoir
améliorer les situations non nous ne
faisons pas preuve de mécontentement
nous constatons qu'il ya certains
résultats
de certains politiques et je pense que
j'ai pu montrer que ce qui se produit
aujourd'hui sur les marchés gaziers
c'est en quelque sorte
le résultat d'une politique qui n'était
pas lucide mais ça c'est leur problème
nous sommes prêts à participer aux
activités communes pour que ces
problèmes ne surviennent pas mais pour
ceux ci on doit avoir comme je viens de
le dire un dialogue honnête et franc
nous rencontrons très souvent nos
partenaires en europe de façon régulière
et je crois que
il y a une compréhension de la nécessité
de d'établir ce dialogue mais nous
allons voir comment cela va donc se
passer en pratique
les européens ont aussi une sorte de
montée de confiance par rapport à la
russie non seulement à cause de la crise
et qu'on ait aujourd'hui sur le marché
gazier
mais aussi à cause de la présence de
dizaines des milliers de soldats russes
à la frontière ukrainienne
comment vous allez résoudre ce problème
de manque de confiance avec vos
partenaires européens est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à coopérer avec nos
partenaires avec le temps oui bien sûr
nous sommes prêts à communiquer en
directement avec
nos partenaires y compris avec le temps
en ce qui concerne nos soldats il se
trouvait sur le territoire us c'est vrai
que nous avons effectué une manoeuvre
très importante
occident un pas de 20h mais nous avons
procédé à ces manoeuvres
sur notre territoire alors que nos
partenaires américains passent à des
exercices aussi important mais à des
milliers de kilomètres de leur
territoire pourquoi ne pas faire des
exercices
près de washington bien new york son
panneau qui sont venus près de
washington et de new york sont eux qui
sont venus près de notre frontière
encore une fois nous nous avons procédé
à des manoeuvres sur notre propre
territoire et nous n'allons pas rendre
des comptes à personne de cette
situation alors que le partenaire un
même donc détruisent les accords qu'ils
ont été
qui ont été obtenues
par exemple l'élargissement de l'otan
vers l'est ça concerne les dispositions
et déséquilibre dans les états baltes
qu'ils sont observés
nous ne
violons pas de contrat aucun des
contrats nous n'avons quittait aucun de
traiter sur le ciel ouvert sur la
réduction des armes stratégiques ce ne
sont pas nous qui ont fait cela ce sont
nos partenaires me retiens qui ont fait
ça
mais pour se déresponsabiliser donc ils
disent que c'est la russie qui est qui
est coupable
alors que les médias donc
font de la promotion de ses idées dans
l'intérêt de ceux qui les paie donc
aérien qui serait étonnante il serait
extraordinaire ne se passe dans le monde
mais nous nous allons ce que nous
jugeons utile en assurant notre sécurité
car sur nos intérêts parce que
c'est pour cette raison que vous avez
mises au point les armes hypersonique et
qui a une très grande précision qui à la
vitesse de trois matchs dont 3 max et
ses larmes qui est
qui qui est mise au point aux états unis
est notre arme
c'est une
c'est un missile hypersonique de 5 mac
et donc intercontinental qui est déjà en
exploitation en service en russie il
faut dire que d'autres pays développent
ce type de systèmes d'armes aussi parce
que désormais à haute technologie et
vont posséder ce type de systèmes
d'armes prochainement
parce qu'il n'y a rien d'extraordinaire
je voudrais vous a attiré votre
attention sur le fait que impôts c'est
dans ce type de systèmes d'armes et
pour la première fois des vans en autres
concurrents qui est qu'ils sont les
états unis pour les armes des hautes
technologies nous n'en faisons pas abus
nous menaçons personne avec ces armes là
nous sommes prêts à mener des
négociations sur la réduction des
armements offensifs et nous sommes prêts
à tenir compte du fait partant des
intérêts de nos partenaires
américains de tenir compte de la
présence de ces systèmes d'armes que
vous avez évoquées il faut tout
simplement se mettre à la table de
négociation pour commencer une dialogue
et substantielles sur ces sujets mais
nous voyons aujourd'hui que
l'administration actuelle commence à se
mettre à cette voix sur cette voie et
nous développons ce type de contacts
notamment
après notre rencontre
avec le président baden à genève
donc si j'ai pas du début de la course
aux armements
malheureusement la course aux armements
est un marché il a commencé avec le
retrait des etats-unis du traité abm jeu
je voudrais signaler que en 2003 encore
j'ai dit à mes partenaires ne fait pas
ça ne vous retirez pas de ce traité abm
parce que c'est un système fondamental
d'une pièce angulaire de la sécurité
internationale qu'est ce que c'est que
la défense antimissile
il s'agit pas seulement de systèmes de
défense c'est aussi une tentative
d'avoir des avantages stratégiques
en neutralisant le potentiel nucléaire
de notre
de l'ennemi potentiel c'est-à-dire de la
russie soit on doit mettre en place le
même système qui coûte énormément
d'argent
et là on sait pas encore quel sera son
efficacité ou bien il faut mettre au
point un autre système qui va donc
surmonter et riposter à ce système de
abm c'est ce que je dis
ils ont dit
vous faites ce que vous voulez nous
nous allons faire comme si ce n'était
pas contre nous c'est que nous on fait
et maintenant ils nous disent vous avez
ces armes et personnic bien sûr qu'ils
n'ont pas aimé ça mais nous n'avons pas
à les aimer non plus le retrait des
etats-unis du traité abm il faut tenir
compte de ces circonstances qui sont
tout à fait objective et de mener un
dialogue sur cette problématique là
monsieur le président avant de vous
laisser partir je voudrais vous demander
de parler de ce qui se passe en ce
moment en russie
vous avez apparemment un problème depuis
cinq ans on constate la réduction des
revenus réels du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages
10 % du pib dépendent des régions
arctiques or il ya le fond du permafrost
il y à des difficultés structurelles
dans l'économie liées au gaz et au
pétrole cette tension s'accumulent
ronald reagan a dit que la liberté
provient
de
la prospérité
en parlant de la démocratie moderne en
russie un vent vous avez dit que la
russie n'était pas prête à une vraie
démocratie
mais précise d'un sens de ce mot à
quelle étape parce que les réussit en ce
moment je me rappelle pas d'un jour où
j'ai dit là ce n'est pas prête à une
démocratie il ya différentes visions de
la démocratie débattaient de la parole
liberté de conscience
liberté d'organiser des événements dans
dans la rue lorsqu'on europe aux états
unis notamment
les manifestations sont difficiles paix
avec de gaz lacrymogène par exemple est
ce que c'est de la liberté
vous avez fait un signe avec votre tête
effectivement ça ne rappelle pas
tellement la vraie liberté la liberté la
démocratie
doivent être liés à la culture et aux
traditions d'un peuple les etats-unis
sont arrivés en afghanistan sans tenir
compte de la tradition de la culture des
traditions du peuple afghan le résultat
est dramatique
le danger de la croissance de la menace
terroriste est énorme cette
prolifération et du terrorisme a
augmenté dans la région et dans le monde
c'est parce que à l'époque on n'a pas
pris en compte les réalités du pays ceci
concerne tous pays notamment la russie
en parlant de la démocratie en russie il
faut qu'on parte de sa culture de cette
tradition notamment les traditions du
parlement l'histoire du parlement russe
compte plus de 100 ans nous venons
d'avoir une nouvelle faction dans le
parlement nouveau parti qui arrive c'est
comme dans le secteur énergétique il
faut que le vote blanc soit stable sous
le pont soit calme et
sans flamber d'émotions sans flamber
négative il faut que le système
politique de la régie se développe d'une
manière qu'elle la limite des
révolutions dans ce pays ait dépassé il
faut que les situations soient stables
calme avec des garanties des droits de
l'homme pour les russes
il faut garantir le développement du
système social certains disent la
démocratie en russie est morte mais
certains c'est un peu trop mac tu n va
dit un jour les racontars sur ma mort
c'est un peu superflu c'est ce qu'il a
dit si je me rappelle
le parlementarisme en europe souffre
regardez les pays
qui possèdent des parlements
traditionnels il ya beaucoup de
questions autour de la corruption le
lobbyisme aux états unis notamment
qu'est ce que c'est que robin robin
officielle aux états unis c'est une
corruption légalisée c'est clair c'est
clair pour tout le monde mais tout le
monde se tait qu'est ce que c'est que
l'élection indirecte du président des
états unis qui peuvent arriver au
pouvoir trois fois déjà c'était la
solution états unis le président élu a
été élu par une minorité finalement de
des lecteurs
est-ce que nous avons des défauts en
russie bien sûr cela ne veut pas dire
que nous avons plus de défauts que je
vais vous peut-être nous avons même
moins de défauts quant à l'économie
effectivement nous avons des problèmes
économiques donc on se pensait problème
comme dans le monde entier
et revenus des ménages se sont réduites
en
diminuer nous essayons de construire
notre travail de manière à assurer
sur le plan qualitatif sur le plan
quantitatif une augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat
il faut un effort financier il faut un
effort administratif
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas encore
atteint les résultats voulus nous
comprenons par contre quel sont les gens
qui ont particulièrement besoin d'une
assistance bien sûr nous focalisons nos
efforts n'ont d'autres aides sur les
familles qui ont des enfants sur les
personnes âgées ceci d'une manière assez
efficace oui l'impression a augmenté à
plus de 7% 7 5% si je me trompe pas
cette fois peu plus que prévu mais vous
venez de le dire toutes les banques du
monde ya un participant qui est dit
aujourd'hui les banques impriment de
l'argent comme des confettis pas la
banque centrale de russie je vais
rencontrer la présidente de la banque
centrale de russie hier nous avons parlé
de notre politique financière non la
banque centrale de russie n'imprime pas
l'argent comme ça mais nous faisons
partie du système mondial nous
avons une inflation quant au prix de
l'alimentation de plus de 7 5 % mais
dans le monde regardait dans le monde
est justement à cause de l'inspection
sur le marché de l'énergie l'inflation
dans ce domaine est forte nous sommes
faisons partie de ce système nous avons
des problèmes spécifiques également metz
nous sommes sûr qu'avec le soutien des
citoyens russes nous allons résoudre ces
problèmes
monsieur le président
cependant pour la russie la corruption
reste un problème important vous occupez
la
129e position sur 180 dans le
cantal indice de corruption au monde
vous avez parlé de l'oligarque à de
l'époque de boris eltsine qui a
bénéficié de la chute de l'union
soviétique mais pour l'instant la
corruption et le problème des droits de
l'homme persiste est ce qu'il est normal
là que des journalistes renconcé
problème ou que le lot rien que le prix
nobel de la paix un russe
et menacés de persécutions c'est ce
qu'il dit écoutez la persécution des
journalistes c'est un problème est
regardée dans le monde le nombre des
journalistes qui sont morts qui ont
souffert la russie n'est pas le seul
pays au monde qui souffrent de ce
problème bien sûr c'est le résultat du
développement
interne du pays des processus
démocratique se déroule mais il est
difficile là il est pratiquement
impossible de trouver un
pays
où
il ya des médias qui sont financés par
les fonds publics et qui sont tellement
violent par rapport au gouvernement gasp
sommes financent une radio en russie qui
est très virulent
par rapport au gouvernement russe il ya
un jour là et sur deux dans cette radio
qui a un passeport étranger ou
un permis de séjour étrangers et cette
radio continue à
fonctionner bien sûr il faut qu'on
protège le journaliste malheureusement
nous n'arrivons pas toujours à le faire
malheureusement
est ce que vous pouvez
notamment nous promettre que monsieur
mouratov ne seraient pas déclarés agents
étrangers si monsieur me retrouve ne
fait pas de transition par rapport à la
gestion russe si il y à petit il ne
commet pas d'actes qui nous feront le
déclarait agents étrangers bien sûr il
ne sera pas déclarée agents étrangers
mais s'ils essaient de
de le faire sous couverture de son prix
nobel un récent et bien nous
allons nous allons le faire il faut bien
se conformer aux lois russes quant aux
agents étrangers c'est pas nous qui
avons inventé cette notion cette notion
a été inventé le cadre légal dans ce
domaine a été créé aux états unis dans
les années 1930 et justement les médias
russes tombent sous le coup de cette loi
américaine alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
peut le faire aux états unis et on peut
pas le faire et en russie tout ceci se
fait aux états unis ou en russie pour
protéger les processus politiques
internes de l'affluence
externe ces agents étrangers ne sont pas
interdits il effectué des activités
en russie simplement il faut se faire
enregistrer en tant qu agent étranger
aux états unis on peut tomber sous le
coup d'une
d'une procédure pénale donc nous allons
tout faire pour protéger les intérêts de
la fédération de russie si vous
permettait une dernière question
monsieur le président quand cette
situation vous avez servi dans le kgb
est ce que il y a
7 ce groupe de personnes
ce qu'on appelle la cinquième colonne
dirigée par alexis ce navale me
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète tellement
quant à l'opposition parce que vous les
envoyer tout le temps en prison si vous
regardez les participants de ces
manifestations non autorisées ils n'ont
pas tous en prison quand même regarder
et puis quand aux personnes que vous
venez de mentionner c'est pas à cause de
leurs activités politiques qu'ils ont
tété un condamné qui sont en prison mais
à cause des actes qu'ils ont commis
vis-à-vis de leurs partenaires
commerciaux notamment étrangers ils sont
tout est pardonné à plusieurs reprises
d'ailleurs mais les conséquences arrive
un jour quand même il ne faut pas faire
mauvais usage de la confiance de la
société
pour justement arriver à des
avantages économiques sous couverture
des activités politiques je pense la
personne que vous venez de mentionner
ces il l'a fait il a fait ça quant à
l'opposition russe elle est bien vivante
elle fonctionne elle critique les
autorités d'une manière très violente
plus virulent que dans les autres pays
alors vous êtes en russie alors brancher
la radio écoutez ces médias russes la
radio et surtout ces casses forme qui
financent certains de ces médias
le
cette entreprise gasprom vend du gaz en
europe et finance les radios
d'opposition si vous ne savez pas alors
étudié cette problématique vous avez
vous aurez la découverte très
intéressante
effectivement ceci n'a pas empêché
certains nombres d'analystes d'investir
en russie alors nous arrivons à la fin
de notre timing la 20e semaine russe de
l'énergie
des buts monsieur le président je vous
remercie je vous souhaite ainsi qu'à
tous les participants plein succès je
voudrais remercier notre modératrice qui
a su créer une ambiance dans cette salle
pour je veux je voudrais remercier nos
collègues nos amis des entreprises
différentes qui ont pu
arriver malgré leur agenda très chargé
ce sont des entreprises mondiales il
voyage dans le monde entier et pourtant
ils sont venus en russie pour participer
à nos travaux
jeu
j'espère que ceux qui sont à distance ou
ceux qui sont dans cette salle
continueront de travailler continueront
de conférer malgré les difficultés que
vit le secteur énergétique mondiale que
notre opération sera efficace nous le
gouvernement du fait d'actions de russie
et moi votre humble serviteur nous
allons tout faire pour vous assurer des
conditions confortables de
fonctionnement en russie correspondant
notamment aux normes environnementaux et
bien sûr en assurant les bénéfices
maximum pour votre guise nous avons déjà
beaucoup fait
ces années et nous allons faire encore
plus dans les intérêts du secteur
énergétique
mondial des pays auxquels nous
travaillons je vous remercie de votre
participation au forum aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup